Five,
four,
three,
two.
Yes.
Hello Hannibal.
What's up man?
How are you sir?
I'm good.
Good to see you.
Good to see you too.
You have notes?
Yeah.
I don't know.
So I just wanted to be prepared.
I had,
I've had notes other times but I just
didn't have them written down.
You know what all you had to like get in
your head.
I had him in my head but I'm an older
man now.
Do you mind starting to slip away?
Mine started to slip away so I had some
notes and drink it.
Alpha brain.
And you've got notes.
Yeah.
Dude,
you're ready.
What's her notes?
What do you want to talk about?
What's going on?
Oh,
we don't have to get right into it.
Naturally.
It was just more for like,
you know,
sometimes if stuff leg or something or
if I feel like I don't have something
right.
And then a peak at it real quick.
Oh,
okay.
Right now we fresh.
Oh,
we're fresh.
Good to see you too,
man.
Yeah.
Sorry about Monday.
Oh no worries man.
Shit happens.
I just did not.
I was still in New York.
I just had booked my flight in the
morning and I just could not go.
You just couldn't do.
It was just too tired.
I was,
it wasn't just a tidy,
was just more of a.
just didn't feel like going.
He was just a like to to.
It was the five hour thing and I did it
today.
Actually.
I flew in today,
but it was just that sometimes you just
don't want to do it.
It was just that flight.
I was like,
oh,
I don't know if that's the beautiful
thing about being a young,
successful single man.
You can do whatever the fuck you want to
do.
It was A.
Yeah.
But I'm uh,
excited to be back where it got weird
last time.
Oh,
here.
Yeah.
Last time.
Was the Sam Harris One,
right?
That's,
that's been a year.
Oh yeah,
that's right.
Yeah.
That did get a little weird alcohol.
Alcohol is a motherfucker.
It's amazing.
It's legal.
It is,
it's amazing.
It's like,
what else?
It was just A.
Yeah,
I should have.
I should've went to the comedy store
was.
I still did do,
yeah.
Did a terrible set dj.
Well,
we got trouble set.
We did a podcast.
I got drunk.
And then you hung around for the second
podcast.
Yeah.
You said sit in,
sit in.
It was Sam Harrison.
Who else was it?
It was,
uh,
the guy whose podcast it is.
Oh,
Josh Zap.
Zap,
Zap.
He fucking loved it.
Of course it got crazy.
But yeah,
he loved the controversy,
but you could see it was kind of gross
even though I love Josh.
You could see it while I was going on.
They loved it.
Yes,
yes,
yes.
He was.
Yeah.
He enjoyed it when you were teasing it
out too,
because I started getting messages.
What is this crazy Hannibal?
Sam Harris.
So I'm like,
what the fuck is going on?
Because I knew once I left I was like,
yeah,
that's going to be some weird shit in.
And I was fine it.
But then
I kept on getting messages,
like,
what is this?
When is that coming out?
And everybody saw it live,
didn't they?
No,
they didn't.
It was not a.
right,
because it was Josh Zaps podcast wasn't
mine.
Oh,
that's right.
Yeah,
Fun Times.
Fun Time.
Last time steps was here.
He was talking about killing babies.
Remember that?
Yeah.
It was talking about like maybe she'll
be able to board a baby six months after
it's born.
I was like,
what the fuck are you talking about man?
You.
Did he have notes?
No,
no,
no.
See that's what he hasn't prepared.
You don't have no notes.
She was like,
yeah,
let's kill alive babies.
Let's talk about it.
Gay dudes feel very differently about
babies.
Like they can't make them as long as
they're doing only gay things.
There's no babies being made.
So like,
so detached from the idea of a baby.
Did you think that
Taylor?
I don't know.
I'm just telling you that shit.
Did he have strong points?
No.
Straight up.
Killed a baby who's just being
controversial.
Okay.
No,
he,
I think he enjoys controversy.
Yeah.
Click Bait.
Hey,
if you're not a comedian,
that's a good way to get attention.
Clickbait.
What else do you have?
You know,
I mean,
everybody can have a good point,
right?
You know,
like can you yell about it?
Well,
if.
Yeah,
can you make a meme about it?
I mean we're,
we're our whole society,
like our news runs on click bait now.
It's getting more and more slippery.
You know,
me and my friends would call everything
fake news now.
Call each other fake news like,
yeah,
I'm going back and forth with the Ra and
Bert and Thompson girl because they
wrote some article about Bert Kreischer
and Bert is gonna swear off of Booze for
90 days?
Yeah,
this is the new bed.
He's going to run a marathon and swear
off booze for 90 days with.
Okay.
I don't believe it.
Where's he at now?
Has He started yet?
He gets drunk every day.
That's what the point.
You're going to die like amy winehouse.
That's how amy winehouse died.
Yeah,
that's what I said,
man,
that's rough.
You can't.
You gotta be like,
no,
you got to be honest with your friends.
Like going to die.
Like amy winehouse can just go cold
Turkey.
I told them to lay off.
I go,
you've got to wean off the booze.
No.
Heroine,
heroin.
You die like that.
No,
no,
no.
You just get the shakes and you feel
like shit,
but heroin,
you could live.
Booze is one of the rare drugs that will
kill you if you drop it cold Turkey if
you're an alcoholic.
But do you think.
I think there's a difference between
heavy drinker.
Oh yeah.
Alcohol.
Oh,
well,
yeah.
Casual Boozer,
you know,
like if you booze,
like maybe if you have like two or three
drinks at night and then quit cold
Turkey will be fine.
But if you're one of those all day
drinkers.
Yeah.
And then you quit cold Turkey,
you will die.
It's very common.
It's a,
it's one of the more common drugs that
you die.
I think there's,
um,
there's a like Benzos,
those,
those will kill you from withdrawal.
There's a few different pharmaceuticals.
It'll kill you from withdrawal,
but I don't believe heroines on that
list.
I think it's very rare that people die
from heroin withdrawal or they get
really sick.
You know,
Carl Hart is Dr Carl Hart,
the famous doctor who is trust all
doctors with just two syllables in it.
Full name.
Well,
he's got dreadlocks.
He trusted me more.
It's cool.
Um,
but he,
uh,
he's a very,
very interesting doctor because he talks
about like drug use and drug with.
He's like,
for first of all,
one of the things that he points out,
it was like,
oh,
let's talk about a drug free society.
It's like there's never been one.
He goes,
there's never been one.
There's never been a drug for you and
you don't normally want it.
He goes when it comes to whether it's
caffeine or alcohol and then
pharmaceutical drugs,
things that help people.
He's like,
we have this.
We decided to demonize certain drugs and
he's like,
the drugs you've got to be worried about
like alcohol's ones carries once because
if you quit cold Turkey,
if you're a hardcore drinker and you
drink and all the time
you'll fucking die.
Look baby cough syrup to wean yourself
off or something like that.
I don't think it helps.
I don't think it activates the same part
of your brain.
You know,
I was talking to a photographer,
I was at this festival this weekend and
she had a,
uh,
a film camera,
you know,
do you develop your fifth?
She's,
oh no,
you can only develop black and white
because if you develop your color
pitches,
the fumes,
well it'll knock you right out.
And so I said,
so just a little bit of that would be a
great time.
It's a small,
so just get a little bit of that and you
can just huffing paint.
Yeah,
you can do a Goddamn job interview it.
Maybe just a little bit of touch,
just like crack a vial in front of Mike,
grow dose of a little bit of that.
Have you ever tried poppers?
Poppers are those little things where if
they crack and they sniff it.
Emile nitrate to thing it's called.
No,
I did whip us in college.
Oh yeah,
I did that when I worked at a creamery.
I worked at Newport creamery.
It was like a ice cream place and they
had a there.
The ice cream was a big vats that what
is the gas?
Nitrous oxide oxide,
right?
Yeah,
that's what it is.
Yeah.
And we would,
uh,
we would do
like socks off of it.
That kills a lot of brands.
I remember I did one weekend in college
and then I think I did it on a Friday
night and on the Sunday I was just
walking on.
I don't know if I was forced into Yale
just because I was trying to justify how
I felt or if it was a natural yell,
but yelling was happening.
Wow.
Yeah,
and you couldn't help it.
I don't know,
something you ever just tweak out by
yourself.
Just you ever.
You never did.
You absolutely do.
After like a crazy workout
after work,
I'm usually spent a week out do
Carter at the
way in.
Was just tweaking out,
but it was for show.
So tell you,
put a show for yourself.
Change your state of mind just by
yourself.
Yeah.
Like people say,
if you smile,
change your mind.
Right?
It will change the way your brain
actually feels.
Well,
if you freak out,
it probably does that too,
right?
Yeah,
yeah,
definitely.
There's ways to do it.
I mean why wildwood Indians,
native Americans,
when they would do those,
those battle cries.
Why else are they doing that?
Getting fired up?
You get hyped up by yelling or singing a
song.
Viking.
Is that a New Zealand New Zealand,
isn't it?
Yeah.
Where they,
uh,
they will play this video of them
playing the USA team.
Oh yeah.
And they're doing this elaborate thing
they're doing.
It's very elaborate and just energetic
and they cut to the USA team and they're
kind of looking back,
Kinda just con.
Not Confused,
but just what's going on.
And they went through this whole thing.
Is this right here?
Yeah.
And they didn't a basketball game.
Basketball,
some volume.
This is ridiculous.
Basketball
and
dusted by 45 points.
You're playing NBA superstars.
You fucked the dummies,
but it's just for the culture.
That's what they do all the time.
But it's.
But it's just,
it seems so stupid.
It seems stupid if you.
Have you played basketball and stupid?
No,
I think if you.
It's a performance art,
like the,
the other players clapped.
Clapped like good,
good job.
Children.
And then that game.
What was the final score that game?
One hundred million to zero.
Is that what it was weird.
If you do all of that and then you're
asking kit kid,
that's,
that is one of the most unfair things
every day like nba superstars play in
the Olympics.
That is so fucked up.
It was in our country country,
but it's so fucked up.
It's so fucked up.
It's like,
look,
Andre Ward was an Olympic gold medalist,
but if you let him boxing the Olympics
right now,
it will be so fucked up.
It's just wrong.
Well,
because,
uh,
just way better than the box in the
Olympics.
They don't let the professionals.
Is it an age cap?
It
was,
it just.
No,
it's just,
I don't think they allow professionals
where,
although that whole professional
nonprofessional things very,
very weird now,
especially now that they let nba players
play,
you know,
because like there was always talk of
that.
Like when they were talking about doing
that,
like it was back when Mike Tyson was a
champion.
Then we're like,
well,
what the fuck?
What have you let Mike Tyson box the
Olympics.
Good luck.
Well,
the,
the players from the other teams I pros
to.
Yeah,
I mean the,
the uh,
whenever that other countries,
well,
Spain had some solid plans and some of
them are NBA players.
Paula,
all marcus saw a rudy guns [inaudible],
a couple of other players that played in
the NBA.
Australia actually put up a,
a decent team.
They got bogut.
Maybe Patty Mills,
I might be fucking out,
but they have a handful of,
a handful of pros from other countries
and in those pro leagues that have been
competitive against but not those guys,
which there's pros and then there's
American pros when it comes to
basketball,
there's no competition.
It's kind of a joke,
isn't it?
It's getting close for a second for a
little bit.
Skinny Spain and Spain has some guys and
spans a bunch of guys in the league.
So it's within Spain plays a USA.
It's basically like some NBA players
playing against other nba players,
you know what I mean?
Versus random dudes.
It instead of it being random dudes from
Spain,
it's actually,
you know,
they might be playing,
one of the guys on USA might be playing
against one of their real NBA teammates.
Interesting.
Yeah.
The rules are a little different to a
international basketball.
What's the,
what's the difference?
For instance,
you can go 10,
but once the ball hits the rim,
you can swat it off and an MBA and an
all American basketball pretty much.
You can't even touch the ball if it's
anywhere close to the rim or above it.
It's like a.
that's a whole act like that's a whole
extra rule if you're like,
if you're a seven foot tall,
right.
You can just snatch the ball every time
I get to near the room.
Basically.
It's a couple of other little small ones
like bumping into.
It's interesting how other countries
used to used to be a noncompetitive in
certain sport.
Like boxing is a perfect example.
For the longest time,
like the American boxers were head and
shoulders above the rest of the world.
Then?
Yeah,
like especially like in the heavyweight
division,
it wasn't even close there.
Like there was Henry Cooper who hurt
Muhammad Ali real bad.
That was an interesting story.
This is back on.
Muhammad Ali was still cassius clay
before he became a home and wait,
and Henry Cooper was like the big
English heavyweight and he rocked
Mohammed Ali with a left hook and you
know what Angelo Dundee did.
He cut Muhammad Ali's gloves.
He went back to the corner and he sliced
his gloves and he's like,
Hey,
we got to change these gloves.
These gloves are fucked up.
So they bought them all this time.
They had an
oh shit.
Yeah,
they had an undo the tape,
get another pair of gloves,
like the cut his fucking gloves because
that's the type of tricks you can do in
the sixties.
Yeah,
yeah,
exactly.
Yeah.
That's what they did.
But he,
if you ever see the fight,
he got cracked like more than he ever
got cracked in his entire career.
But Google Henry Cooper a rocks Mohammed
Ali.
And so Mohammed Ali,
it wasn't Muhammad Ali was Cassius clay
back then,
so he drops him with like the perfect
left hook that was his big punch to and
Ali just crashes down to his ass and
he's like out and they,
they gave them all sorts of time.
He went back to the corner,
they cut the gloves,
they took the gloves off,
then he went back and got new gloves.
They had to,
they sliced slices,
gloves open with a razor blade,
sliced him about 10 minutes.
This whole lot of time.
Anytime.
A lot of time because they had to get
gloves,
you know,
they don't have gloves is waiting.
What was a.
I Wonder what the commentators stall
game was.
See it right here.
What are these guys used to stolen right
here.
Boom.
Oh yeah.
Like he is fucking out.
Got His rock and it's end of the round.
The very end of the rounds.
Boom.
I mean as a perfect left hook.
It just got sat down.
He's in deep trouble.
So there's two things happen.
One is the end of the round.
See?
He's like really out of it here.
Like Shit.
Yeah,
they're throwing water on him and then
when they go back they're like,
oh,
you know,
so they cut it out of this.
They don't show.
They changed the gloves.
So he's super fresh year and he wound up
to be stopping Henry Cooper by cut.
See if there's a clip of the glove
changing.
That's funny.
It's like,
this is a Mike Tyson's old train.
Not old trainer,
but old manager.
Goddammit.
I forget his name,
but he was a boxing historian and he put
together all of these videos and he used
to do the voiceover for a lot of these
videos to like right when custom Otto
died.
Him and Shelly Finkel took over.
God Damn it.
What the fuck is his name?
Mike Tyson's old manager.
What do you got there?
Pulling it up,
bobby?
Nope.
There's an old Jewish guy.
I forget his name,
but he was a.
He had a tremendous library of films.
Yeah,
that's one of the things that uh,
Mike Tyson used to go and watch,
you know,
obviously we're talking about the early
eighties,
so this is before vhs tapes or raw.
I mean,
those things weren't on vhs tapes,
so he would watch them like on 16
millimeter film.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
God Damn.
I'm struggling to remember his fucking
name.
It's driving me crazy.
Something with a J.
Anyway,
point being,
he probably edited that out,
who didn't want to show the controversy
because it was plain straight cheating.
They just cheated.
I want to hear the,
what the commentators did during that
stall point.
Oh,
we don't know what's going on.
Or did they just veer off into other Ta
sometimes how baseball commentators just
start talking about some weird random
shit about their family
is downside,
you know,
went out fishing in lake is great,
man.
The mosquitoes get to you,
but.
Okay.
Yeah.
Hi.
In a way,
baseball players.
It's an art to that,
right?
Because there's so much downtime.
Yeah,
it's A.
Oh absolutely.
It's so much downtime.
I was watching one clip,
I forget what Teva was,
but it was a,
just of the,
it was
somebody at bat and then one of his
teammates was just exactly Mike and his,
his,
uh,
just imitating his batting style and
ritual.
Just each from like every little nuance
to just what he would do with his left
foot and just.
And He,
and then he was doing that for all his
teammates because you got so much
downside that you,
him and you around them a 162 games and
plus practice.
So you're like,
yeah,
I know exactly all of your moves or your
mannerisms.
Exactly.
Every one of your mannerisms down to the
eye.
Twitch,
my high school wrestling coach refused
to call baseball sport.
He's like,
it's not a sport skill,
skills,
game,
skills game.
But you do have to run,
you have to run.
This is not my favorite sport,
but I respect it a lot.
Um,
I don't,
I,
you know,
heavy biases from the cups.
I don't know anybody was playing
baseball once they get arrested,
that's a lot of you got to be arrested
or you gonna fuck j Lo.
That's how a lot of people found out.
Hobby Baez is one of the best defenders
and elite makes incredible plays.
And where you like,
that's,
that's athletics.
If somebody.
Oh for sure.
But it's,
it's a lot of skill involved,
but it's definitely it.
Definitely athletes.
I think.
Yeah,
they are,
but it's like there's a big gap between
dad and say like basketball,
like you have to be in some extreme
cardio,
right?
Basketball,
you're running back and forth and back
and forth and you know,
those guys are always sore after games
and you know,
they got fucking plantar fasciitis and
shoulder issues.
Constant activity is no,
you know,
you can be in left field a couple of
minutes and not do anything.
Just chilling out there with your own
thoughts.
Talking to the fans and shit.
Yeah,
it's none of that in basketball just
standing around except for during free
throws or downtime.
But baseball players might go,
especially if the pitcher is killing it.
Yeah.
You just,
you just get into your fucking stands
halfheartedly and.
But you know,
it might not be coming out there.
That's the other thing about baseball
fans will torture you if you're sitting
out there.
Oh yeah,
that's a long time to be out there on a
away game plus the drinking.
There's 18 minutes of action.
Your average major league baseball game,
that's like less than one fight.
Eighteen minutes actually,
that's like one championship fight or
less than less than one championship
fight or basically one slash three round
fight,
which is 15 minutes of action.
That's crazy.
We acted like we made a big discovery in
shit.
Yo.
Baseball borrowing.
Yeah,
we did it.
Well.
Baseball is one of those games,
like if you tried to invent it today,
they'd be like,
get the fuck away from there with DNA.
That shit is definitely old school.
But the other thing about that 18
minutes of action,
that's not even action of
everybody that's in that.
Everybody moving at once,
like a football game or basketball.
That's maybe three or four people moving
around.
Yeah,
depends.
Usually if you turned on the double play
then you know it was a handful of people
involved in.
But yeah,
it's pretty boring.
Shit,
I ain't get paid a lot.
A lot of games.
I guess it's crazy how much money is
involved in it.
People I get mad,
but it's gone to like Japan.
Where else?
What other countries adopted baseball
adopted it took it a super popular in
Japan.
I know Cuba.
Cuba,
right.
I take it maybe Mexico,
Mexico on a career.
I'm just saying stuff.
Yeah.
I don't know.
Just guessing.
It's amazing how little interest people
here have for soccer.
That's what's really amazing.
When you say a soccer worldwide and see
how little we give a fuck about it here,
except those annoying white dudes that
like to get really hyped up about it.
When the World Cup comes around and they
scream and yell at bars like they really
give a fuck.
This reportedly growing belief that
Bryce Harper's next contract could be
worth over $400,000,000.
I couldn't imagine Jesus just a that
type of a serious scrutiny and attention
on my finances like that.
Brian has expectation.
This is not even.
Not The contract is set yet,
but when people are talking about what
you might make so much money,
it's a lot of money.
It's too much money,
too much money to be resting over your
head,
sink full of hundreds to well say.
It's about.
I don't know.
I mean it depends on what state he lives
in,
how much money it actually is.
Well,
it becomes a thing like with floyd
mayweather,
you know,
like a big thing about floyd mayweather
is how much money he makes is not just
that he's a great boxer,
it's that he's going to make
$300,000,000.
Apparently it's going to be even more
than that.
And you see the paper view numbers,
they're talking about six point $5,
million pay per view buys,
so it's more than 2 million more than
the manny Pacquiao fight.
That's insane.
Does that include the potential refunds
today?
That's a good question.
Well to be fair,
he did nickname himself money
mayweather.
Well he did after he was pretty boy
floyd.
He changed it,
but yeah.
Then he built the persona around.
I spend money.
Yes.
He doesn't have to do.
I mean it is.
It's cool and good for him,
but he did make a big thing about
spending money that one time he showed
up like $100,
million dollar check.
Stupid.
Like,
wait,
why is that?
Unlike a regular ass check on a regular
chase bank check.
It wasn't even a big cardboard one night
even net or print out
or print it out on a or even a wire or
something.
I will get that wired.
Yeah.
Laminate that thing is real.
He's really holding onto a $100,000,000
check.
But it was just a regular as check that
you would buy groceries on in the
eighties.
Yeah.
That $100 million.
I guess he wrote it to himself.
So it's made with it promotions general
for.
Yeah.
You got 100 million and a bank of
America I guess.
So it seems like he just holds onto it
too.
Hey,
he doesn't catch it.
That's a weird.
Out of his book bag at one of the uh,
yeah,
but I mean why is he hanging on onto
that?
Why did you should probably catch that
was his other account anyways.
It's mainly where the promotions
account.
Who Cares?
So the bay where the personal account,
the checking.
So he's probably gonna make more than
$300.
Million Dollars from this last fight.
Sure.
Yeah.
Amazing.
I can't imagine that they won't do that
again.
That him and connor won't do it again
with a wet finger.
Konica figure out how to not get tired.
If he could convince people like say if
he fights Paulie Malignaggi he's beats
the shit out of Paulie Malignaggi and
then says Freud,
let's do it one more fucking time.
And I think Florida.
Nah Man.
Come on.
We did that.
Know,
I know he starts thinking about that
money could.
If you could figure out a way to get
people excited about it.
Connor could get somehow somehow or
another get more people to pay attention
because it was an interesting fight for
the first three or four rounds.
It's made it.
He made it look interesting,
but it really wasn't interested.
I thought it was interesting.
But then when I thought back it wasn't
interested.
Well he caught clean.
You know,
he caught him with an upper cut in the
first round.
Nobody hits fully clean like that.
Lloyd underestimated in my thoughts.
So wasn't.
He wasn't doing that shoulder roll?
No,
he was.
Because he wanted to.
He didn't believe in Conexpo.
So floyd usually boxes anything.
That's what it is when you always see
them boxing that like he blocked Canelo
and he does that and and he goes off of
that counter.
I don't think that's what it was.
I think he knew that conner was going to
get tired if he was backing up.
He knows that connor has a endurance
problems and as long as he wasn't
throwing a lot of punches,
which floyd wasn't,
and he's constantly faking and moving.
He's got connor backing up.
He could be.
It's way easier to be defensive if
you're not being authentic.
So if you're not thinking about hitting
the guy,
if you're constantly like fainting and
you've got your hands up,
you're moving forward,
but really what you're thinking about is
what he's throwing.
You can get away with a lot and you
could press for it a lot more because
you're going to see the punches coming
because you're not really thinking too
much about throwing your own punches
unless he's like a clear wide opening.
So for the first couple of rounds he was
mostly like putting pressure on them,
sizing him up.
When I watched it after the fight,
it became way more obvious,
like while you're watching it,
you're like,
what's gonna Happen?
What's gonna happen once you already
know what's what's happened then.
Then I watched it and I said,
oh,
I could see exactly what he's doing.
He's fainting,
putting a lot of pressure on conor and
he's making kind of backup a lot,
which exists is exhausting.
And then also connor's not very
efficient.
He's not a boxer.
So like there's a lot of energy being
wasted.
Like he's going to get tired more easily
and then he doesn't run so he doesn't
have the same kind of endurance of floyd
has.
It's a lot.
A lot of factors in there.
Yeah,
it was 111 punches,
but some of them were like,
yeah,
all the ones that connor landed.
You mean there was a few of them.
They were like little [inaudible] yeah.
Yeah.
There were also like weird ones like
Patty Patty,
patty punches to the side of the head in
the back of the head.
This is one main it kind of this and it
just is this box and shit.
Well,
you know,
you get used to that in mma,
you get used to hammer fists.
Well I think that's what I saw.
I was talking about the and a lot of
other people were just wondering if
muscle memory is going to just kick in
and he was going to do some weird
information and it did kick it a little
bit,
but not to the extreme.
Yeah,
I think there was some massive penalties
for any.
So if he had any sort of a point
deduction or anything that they did
something illegal.
I think he had a massive penalty more
than a million dollars for each thing.
He fucked up 10
mil.
10 Mil makes them for each one.
That makes sense.
At that 10 mil makes you get your shit
together.
As long as he's not,
doesn't get disqualified.
It might be worth it like 10 million for
one fucking needed of the body.
You know,
I,
I didn't know you used to fight until
after the last time I did the podcast.
I just thought you have got to work out
a lot and just really liked mixed
martial arts and combat.
But I never fought in mixed martial arts
because he wasn't around.
But a kickboxing.
Yeah,
I did that.
Yeah.
Because I remember just seeing
something.
Somebody said,
Oh,
you talking about rogen like that.
He'll kick you in your shit.
And I'm like,
what?
And then I looked up Rogan.
Kickboxing.
Huh?
What the fuck?
This whole time
she was kicking the shit out of her
back.
Yeah.
How'd that feel,
man,
to hit somebody feels weird.
The bag.
Oh,
bags.
Easy.
Yeah.
Bags don't hit back.
When's the last time you hit somebody
in?
In anger or in a competition?
It's been a long fucking time.
It was anger.
Neither one.
Neither one's in longer.
Anger and anger is probably a highschool
hold.
Competitions when I was 22 or something
like that,
that was a taekwondo tournament.
I was 19 then.
Oh,
and that was you.
The walk off those.
Meet with the Walker.
Have you kicked so of the body like
that?
A spinning back kick to the body.
So much bulletproof.
Doesn't matter that thing.
That's just moral protection.
Oh Man.
So what was your at that moment when you
saw him laying down and he's dead?
I knew he was gone,
but I'm not dead.
And you know,
taken Tam.
He's not getting up.
Was it like.
Yeah,
you have to walk away and make it look
like it's no big deal.
That was how my thought process was.
Don't get excited.
Make lives like this is what I'm going
to do to everybody.
Just relax.
Just walk off and have everybody so
nervous.
So you don't even care.
Like this is just a normal thing for
you.
You kick people to go unconscious,
they fall down,
they can't get up that you gotta have
that people because you're in a
tournament.
So you're going to be fighting a bunch
of people and then watch it.
Yeah.
You might have to fight three or four
times in a day.
Who was there rooting for you to see my
teammates because of the train with no,
it doesn't even seem like even more I
watch.
That doesn't really feel like me so long
ago.
Just a hair.
Well,
not only that,
I mean I also have a head protector on
the back of my hand.
They would wear these a head protectors.
Either you could wear a full one that
covers your whole head,
like over your ears or you were one
that's just the back of your head,
which is really just there.
So when you get knocked out,
your head doesn't need fucking bounce
off the ground.
Yeah,
because we were fighting on a basketball
court.
You look at that,
that's just a wood floor shit.
Yeah,
there's a lot of that fun on the hockey
rink once where they put a plastic sheet
down on a hockey rink.
So it was a,
not the ice but the cement underneath
the hockey rink.
So we were basically fighting on cement.
So the eighties with terrible is fucking
awful bad for brain damage,
that's for sure.
A lot of people who got fucked up,
knocked out and bounce their head off
the ground.
Jesus,
I saw a lot of that.
Oh not good.
And for no money,
that's the thing.
There's no future,
no future and no money for the love of
the game.
Well,
I guess it prepares you for life and
also you wanted to find out.
I wanted to find out how I would.
Do you know,
I wanted to find out what it would be
like to compete under high stress
situations.
Like worrying about someone kicking you
in the face.
Yeah.
I'm glad that most people can't kick
somebody in the face,
so I'm glad that's whatever I go to UFC
fight or even made the ad just whenever
somebody gets kicked in the face and if
I got kicked in the face.
Have you sold disappointed?
It's not good.
It's not.
It looks.
It looks crazy.
Yeah.
It's terrible for you.
The thing is more people can kick people
in the face now than I think at any
other time in human history.
I think there's a lot of fucking people
that can kick people in the face now
because of watching MMA and internet and
classes training.
I think more people training now than.
Than ever before for sure.
There's way more people that could
strangle people than ever.
Oh yeah.
One hundred percent because the choke is
easier to learn now.
It's just more people doing Jujitsu than
any other time in history.
Like before,
like in my early martial arts days,
there was no one that was doing
grappling really.
Like I wrestled in high school and then
there was no like Jujitsu classes.
There was like you could take judo,
like there was judo,
but there was very few like actual
submission grappling schools or anything
like that.
Even nationwide there was a small
handful.
Nobody knew what the fuck they were
doing.
Now everywhere you look,
there's a Jujitsu school.
Like I was down in San Diego,
just San Diego alone,
which is not a big city.
They must have 100 Jujitsu schools
just in San Diego.
Shit.
Crazy.
I'm going to start sponsoring more
fighters.
Yeah.
Are you remember?
I sponsored a and she.
Ms Dot wait.
Yeah.
And INVICTA,
right?
Yeah.
She's going to do more.
I am.
Some other people reached out.
I got to just get some new designs for
the club.
That's what's been holding me back.
I gotta get some new designs that will.
That was an okay design,
but I had a mix up like your face on her
ass or something like that.
Is that the whole body?
It wasn't just last day.
It was,
it was just in case,
you know,
just in case she got knocked out and
fell on her face.
Did Hannibal buress I come,
yeah.
Yeah.
You could do it in some organizations
still.
There it is.
Oh yeah.
All over it.
She didn't make weight.
That didn't make weight.
I think it's harder for girls to make
weight.
Well she.
Well she's.
She's fighting next week at.
I think she was trying to fight at 1:15
and she's fighting at 1:25 now or she
was trying to fight.
I think she's trying to fight at one.
Oh,
five and now fight.
They want either.
Was she cutting much weight?
She's cutting this weight this time.
That was the other thought about the
conor fight.
A lot of people thought that connor cut
too much weight.
That's one of the reasons why I burned
out.
Yeah,
it's part of it.
I think it was a factor.
He does cut a lot of weight and that
does drain your body and it's not like
when he's training,
he's cutting that Wayne because he's
not,
you know,
like you only do it once,
you do it right before the weigh ins
you weigh in and then you put the weight
back on.
So all that endurance training,
all this hard rounds that you did,
that's not after you're dehydrated
yourself severely.
So your body's not used to operating
exactly that level with this situation.
Yeah,
well he's used to it
because he fights in mma like that,
but mma,
you get more chances to take a break.
You get.
It's,
it's different.
You know,
it's more exhausting,
like it could potentially be more
exhausting because there's grappling and
there's kicks and there's just a lot
more going on and you're fighting five
minute rounds,
like you have more of a chance to get
tired in that five minute rounds,
but when you clench with someone,
you could actually hold onto them,
like referee's not going to break it.
You can take them to the ground and get
on top of them.
You couldn't hold your position and
catch your breath.
There's there's more opportunities to
recover.
Right?
At weight cutting is the worst part of
fighting.
One hundred percent seems.
It was even the fighter that a judge was
opposed to fight that day.
She took a picture of herself and she
made weight,
but it looks terrible.
It was definitely one.
Oh,
five.
Not at our member [inaudible].
One 15 wouldn't look crazy,
like,
well it could if you were fine.
It was just like,
she's like,
I waiting.
I was like,
Oh,
you okay?
It was just a.
She put it phone on.
I.
I'm like,
you know what,
that she tried.
She tried to make wait shit.
Who Cares?
A few pounds,
but I guess those few pounds matter.
Obviously somebody is overweight and
didn't go through the strenuous process
that you went to today.
Minute advantage.
Yeah.
You have an advantage if you're not
dehydrating yourself as much,
but that advantage is crazy.
Like they should stop doing that.
They really should figure out a way to
stop fighters from cutting weight like
that.
What's the alternative?
The alternative is to weigh them like
randomly the same way they catch people
that drugs like when like random drug
tests do random weight tests,
like they show up and they go,
oh Hannah,
but look,
you're 175 pounds.
You're supposed to be fighting at 1:55.
What the fuck is that?
Like,
okay.
And then they catch you again.
Okay,
well you're 176 pounds today.
All you're definitely not fighting at
1:55.
And they'll,
they'll give you a way parameter.
Like it says it's healthy for you to cut
10 pounds.
You've got to fight at one 66.
That's your weight class.
So it'll force fighters to be more
disciplined about their actual weight.
Like you can't balloon up in between
rounds or in between competition.
And you're also,
you know,
you have to think about how much weight
you could actually dehydrate out of your
body.
Healthy California has some new Ra laws,
like they only let you cut a certain
amount of weight.
Like they'll,
uh,
they,
they periodically measure people like
during their camp and give them an
opportunity and they measure them during
the camp.
And those was one of the reasons I
hadn't Barao who was the bantamweight
champion.
He fought aljamain sterling,
but they wouldn't let him fight at 1:35.
They made them fight at 1:40 [inaudible]
like he cut too much weight
catch weight.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Uh,
I think that should be the option for
the crazy fired is just to whatever
weight you want to be class,
that'd be one like foot fires that might
not be active on that on the bill.
And we got the spot like guest but the
guest,
but guest by on the comedy.
So you know,
somebody just pops up,
hey pop up fight.
No matter what the way it is,
these two fighters,
they whatever the fuck wait,
they want to be,
they've agreed to fight.
We got this guy coming in and one 65,
this other guy coming in at 2:15.
They agreed to fight each other.
You're cool with that.
Like old school?
UFC One?
Yeah,
like the old school,
but not crazy,
you know that sumo wrestler versus you
know,
100 pound dude.
But
how much weight?
Thirty pounds difference like that cat
was the cap.
I think it's up to late.
Leave it up to the person.
A guest is the guest spot.
Well,
lot of
people do that in a grappling
tournaments and grappling tournaments.
They have the absolute division and the
absolute division.
Sometimes the lighter guys when the
whole thing.
Yeah,
but there's no hitting.
That's the thing about grappling,
you know,
it's like you can,
you can get by and skill and technique
and an understanding your positioning
where like know you're fighting a guy
like,
like Francis
in Ghana or something like that.
It's just a giant 265 pound dude.
If you're 150 pound guy,
you're fucked.
You're just fucked.
That guy.
He's what?
Eight something or he's 10 and 1:10 and
one.
Yeah,
I think he lost one of his early fights.
The commission.
Okay.
Look that they have a 10 point plan to
curb the weight.
Cutting a while.
Protecting fighters now normalized in
the commission's rules are steeper,
fine for missing.
Wait a 10 percent cap on the way to
fighter is allowed to gain between the
time the weigh ins.
Oh,
that's interesting.
And an event,
uh,
and the weight class restrictions for
those who miss weight more than once,
they also recognized for new weight
classes.
I think that's huge.
Have a bunch of weight class.
They should have weight classes every 10
pounds.
That Guy Andy Foster,
he's the California State Athletic
Commission Executive Director.
He's the shit.
That guy's awesome.
He really is the most proactive at of
all of the athletic commission guys.
So that's it.
They'll figure it out.
They banned the use of [inaudible],
which is interesting too because ivs
help you considerably to rehydrate.
Sure.
Yeah.
They banned him.
Yeah,
they banned them.
They don't want people relying on that
because thirsty
punched fight.
Just all these articles about a Kevin
Doran about talking shit about under
armour.
Dude,
that crushed their stock yesterday.
It's easy.
It's the trump of basketball shoe
stocks.
No.
You know what he did?
He's just like casually commenting about
like how kids will pick schools based on
what,
um,
uh,
sneakers.
They're going to have to wear it.
True.
Yeah.
Oh,
started to rent.
Takes a shot at under armor.
But he just said it and like in a matter
of fact,
sort of a way,
it's like kids don't want to play an
under underarmour.
So you look at this.
Nobody wants to play in under armour.
I'm sorry.
The top kids don't because they all play
Nike on a podcast.
Podcast interview dropped the stock.
Is that what it was?
A podcast,
a ringer podcast.
It dropped the stock three percent.
Much money.
That must be for a giant company like
under armour.
Three percent.
That's a billion dollar plus company.
Three percent is probably tens of
millions of dollars.
Right?
Get a bounce back though.
How much is the,
the actual difference?
Uh Oh,
it's slow.
It's down 44 percent assessed to start a
year.
Oh,
that's not good if it's already been
slight.
Yeah.
There's a lot of issues with under
armour and hunting too.
A lot of people think that under armour
is a,
they're,
they're worried about their hunting
division because like anti hunters,
they,
they're like the only gigantic company
that has the stones to support something
that's controversial as hunting.
I haven't been around very long though
either.
Right?
Under armour 15 years.
Maybe.
That's a good question.
Like I read that then I think they're
from the nineties.
I read some.
Adidas started back long,
long
time ago and then two brothers and
that's where Puma started as the two
brothers started due to some boom or
something like that.
Or
didas is from run DMC.
My Adidas,
that's like 1980 something.
They're just now rebounding from the
problems.
That nice juicy that quick.
You're a wizard.
You listen,
man,
she's got a hatch up.
Pour it out.
I be professional.
That's The craziest,
fastest pee of you've down three waters
since you've been here,
man.
You lift all this.
Talk about these fighters,
dehydrating yourself.
You know,
fuck that.
I don't have to live by those rules.
Nope,
not in.
Not In this game
we were talking about under armour.
They,
they,
uh,
have a hunting division.
And they take a ton of shit because I
know there's a,
there's a bunch of like crowdfunding
thing,
not crowd funds.
What are those things?
So it wasn't a fun thing.
It was a crowd something or another that
we're going after.
Cameron Hanes,
because they were calling him a trophy
hunter and they were trying to get under
armour to drop him.
But then you look at like how many
people like their,
their hunting divisions is tiny division
and then under armour itself,
the company is just gigantic.
It's very interesting.
There's not a lot of companies that
would be that big that would support
hunting.
Takes a lot of balls.
Yeah.
That means the CEO is definitely into
hunting and he's like,
this is my buddies.
Yeah,
well yeah,
the owners.
And it's like you imagine Nike got into
hunting.
No Way.
He was in golf with Tiger Woods and
obviously he was a gigantic athlete for
them,
but now that he's not out there even
playing golf,
the golf division,
I think they just closed it this year.
Like they don't even make anything
anymore.
They'll make some clothes for and some
shoes,
like they're putting golf spikes on the
bottom of Jordan's,
but like they don't make clubs or
anything anymore I think because what
the Huh.
They just put in golf spikes on the
bottom of just get some of those extra
charges out there from the recalls
section and just talk some spikes on
there and just get them out to the US
Open.
Well we were talking last night about
rappers that get sponsored by shoe
companies at the store.
Like I didn't know that rappers had
contracts with shoe companies.
Nike announces it will no longer make
golf clubs balls and bags.
You said this and I run DMC.
They probably for sure how to contrast.
Yeah.
50 slash fifty cent and Jay Z had a
commercial wrapping back and forth at
each other.
Who else?
Kanye has his own shoe.
He has his own.
He.
Yeah,
but he had it with Nike originally and
then went to adidas.
Uh,
that's the only rappers or could you
imagine if a comic.
Kevin Hart,
Kevin will.
You have to go to the next absolute
level.
Stratosphere as a comic or I mean,
unless you really want to do it and do
it on a,
on a small artisanal level,
then you could.
You could do whatever you want to do.
Yeah.
I guess
that's a.
it's a weird thing though,
that rappers get sponsored by companies
like.
Well,
like Kendrick Lamar,
he's got a.
Some sort of a shoe company thing.
Popular Person.
Huge.
Yeah,
right,
but does that guy work out?
I think Ken's would probably works out
probably because you know what?
It's certain rappers I could tell that
they work out based on this show.
Really?
Oh,
because they have energy.
Well not even just energy,
but if you look,
especially if your songs and your lyrics
are very dense,
where your betterment and you wrap it
up,
that takes a lot of breath control and
cardio.
Especially if you're not doing it.
If you don't have a hype man on stage.
If you a hype man,
the hype man is someone just isn't it?
Just the energy is so you can catch a
breath and so he'll take those last
couple of words on a line and then you
catch your breath and then you come back
because a lot of people don't have the
breath control.
So a lot of times even if somebody is
not ripped,
they're in shape,
they're lungs are in shape.
If they can do a whole a whole show of
just,
you know,
kind of rapid fire songs and shit.
I never thought about that.
A hype man,
Huh?
Yeah.
That's what the hype man.
I mean as far as it's definitely they
bring the energy up,
but a lot of times if you see a rapper
and at their show and they don't have a
hype man,
they're like,
you know,
I could spit my own shit all the way.
I don't need a hype man.
Yeah,
yeah.
Especially if they're fast with their
lyrics.
Right?
Yeah.
And Kendrick does it,
you know,
he doesn't wrap over his own beats.
That's a pet peeve of mine,
a lot of big rappers and they will just
wrap over the song,
the actual song.
Oh,
own lip sync.
And almost pretty much just wrap it over
the shit at their own concert.
Now get sometimes if a,
say you pop up as somebody show to do a
guest spot as a rapper and you do your
biggest song.
This person's Dj doesn't have your
instrumental.
He only has the regular track,
the rap over that.
But it's just show.
I don't want to hear you rap over that
because he was just rapping over as well
produced song.
I'd rather just hear this shit.
Chris being a club,
right?
Yeah.
Just otherwise you're just seeing their
presence.
That's just it.
I mean it's still,
you know,
it's still fun,
but it's just not when you,
when you know what the alternative is,
which is you being a good polished
performance,
then you're like,
come on man.
Just don't wrap up your shit.
Yeah.
That's a weird pop thing.
Right?
Pop singers are kind of allowed to do
that.
We know they do it,
but when they get busted,
it's a huge deal.
Like what was the girl Ashley?
What the fuck?
Nationally,
Samsung.
That was a big disaster,
right?
She kind of vanished after that for that
too bad timing.
Yeah.
She had a show.
They're trying to ramp her up on on TV.
Like the diary of it.
Oh yeah.
They pulled up.
Pulled the plug on that fucker.
That's it for her.
Yeah.
I ever heard about her again.
Not really.
Not really round.
Sorry.
The party.
That was like 15 years ago,
right?
At least
15.
I think it might've been like easy to
easy to where I worked in 2009,
so the couple years before the Atacama
guest.
Oh six for my mom looking at what is it?
Oh Wow.
Yeah.
Damn.
Thirteen fucking years time and we'll
fly.
He does not wait for you.
You got to be.
Yeah.
If you're going to be a person who sings
on stage and moves around on stage and
you're not going to be going over your
track,
you have to be in some serious shape
yet.
It's a to put on a solid show.
Thomas is no music and you just fucking
rebroke
breaking our music now,
but nobody know where to find out.
Yeah,
but this is December 14th.
Two thousand 16 this shit out yet.
She said 45.
Now look at her.
She's got kids and had a whole yoga.
She found she found value in other
things besides show business.
He got to go for probably a good move
for some people,
you know,
just get out now.
We were looking at um,
what the fuck's his name?
Mick Jagger's routine.
Like Mick Jagger's,
185 years old.
And that dude works out twice a day.
Yeah.
Like he does yoga,
he lifts weights.
He has trainers.
I kid,
he's just doing everything to try to
keep his body together.
Like Bang.
And then might want to keep fucking
supermodels.
Is this girl like 27?
Yeah,
he's got like a 18 year old girl.
I trained five,
six days a week,
but I don't go crazy.
I alternate between gym work and
dancing.
Then I do sprints,
things like that.
I'm training for stamina.
He shredded though.
They had a picture of like Mick Jagger,
like his body eight miles a day.
Damn.
He runs eight miles a day.
Swimming,
kickboxing and cycling.
How old is he?
He's got to be like 72.
Right.
Let's.
Let's take a guess.
How old do you think Mick Jagger is?
He's.
Yeah,
he's 77 I think.
Seventy two.
Good.
Yeah.
Seventy two.
Seventy three.
I remember seeing something when we were
kids.
Seventy two year olds were dead.
Absolutely.
There was nothing left and like you,
you had,
you were on empty.
Your body was 74.
He's almost 80.
Was almost 100.
Then how long is he gonna live a
hambrick.
How does melon otherwise girlfriend look
at her hot as fuck.
She's Mickey Dirty Dick.
She's just turned 30 and he knocked her
up,
right?
Didn't he shoot a live one in there?
Yeah.
What are the odds that kid's going to
come out and not have super powers?
All this stuff that he's taken this to
stay young.
Wow,
that's crazy.
Thirty years old.
Here's what I want.
Mick Jagger,
because of the baby.
Giant head look.
The kid can read minds.
The kids heads filled with vitamins and
anti aging serum.
Look at her.
She's like,
Yo,
Daddy's 70 foot.
Yeah,
Daddy's older.
Didn't the president.
We have to find you a positive role
model because your daddy probably won't
be around very much longer.
Have you heard of Maroon five at all
when you're 74 and you're having a kid
that is super ambitious,
like you're optimistic as fuck to be 74
and have a kid?
Yeah.
I'm,
I'm 34 and I'm like,
oh,
I need to get.
If I'm going to have kids I need to get
it in next.
Something happened in the next couple of
years.
Yeah,
that's a good move.
But I would never.
Seventy four of brand new one.
Yeah.
That's super bold.
I guess it's just,
you know,
he's got a great story by that.
You know Theo Vaughn,
do you know thea?
Hilarious dude.
He's fucking hilarious.
Uh,
his dad was like in his seventies when
he had him and he's got hilarious
stories about going to school and like
telling people that's his grandpa and
being embarrassed.
It's his dad.
His Dad was fair falling asleep
everywhere.
It sounds like fair behavior for a kid
who's j dot jaggers.
This girl is first kids 45.
Jesus Christ.
Man.
This first kid could be,
his girlfriend's mom might have an older
one too.
Oh Man.
Is He married to the girl?
The new girl?
It says spouse.
So he's probably like,
why not?
I'll get married.
We don't give a fuck.
Take my partner partner even better.
That's how it needs to give him my money
to my kids.
Partner means fool me twice.
Shame on me three times.
I'm senile.
Oh,
move in and collect on my estate.
His lover.
Lover.
Isn't that funny that we have like
distinctions like did you or did you not
scribble on the paper?
It's just did you or did you not agree
to some stupid shit that doesn't make
any sense financially.
Juha digital.
Is your estate at stake with this
relationship or not?
Can you just shoot it
loads in her random or willy nilly or
does she have access to half of your
money?
Let me know what.
Nope,
she doesn't let me know what's going on.
What's the deal?
What kind of deal would you guys make
that's,
uh,
that,
that deal?
It's just so weird.
I have a friend that is a super rich
dude and he was getting married,
his wife did not want a prenuptial and
he was like,
well this is crazy.
Like why wouldn't I get a prenuptial?
Like if we stay together,
like we don't have to worry about
anything because you know,
you'll,
you'll be fine,
you'll have plenty of money.
But if we break up,
why would I be in a situation where you
could get half my money?
She goes,
you don't think this relationship is
going to last.
That's why it was.
No,
I think it's going to last.
That's why I want a prenuptial
[inaudible] it's not going matter.
Right.
And if,
if,
if it doesn't last,
let's work out a side deal that isn't,
that have.
Yeah.
You can't just hold that over me.
Like,
well his ex wife held it over like
they,
he didn't have a prenup and when they
got divorced it was a disaster.
And so then he was going into a second
marriage and this lady was like,
I don't want a prenup.
And he was like,
what?
I've already done this like the fuck out
of here.
So tough Combo works out.
It works out.
Yeah,
that's a heavy.
I've had some heavy combos in my life,
but that's one of the ones where were
kicking it for a couple years.
But uh,
yeah,
I don't want you to just in case this
goes poorly,
let's just get this out of the way real
quick.
Careful.
Like what stage of the relationship
chip you do this too because in the
beginning,
like if you decide to get married after
like six months,
you're like,
you're on drugs,
right?
You're blessed,
you're blessed out.
He can't believe the relationships
working so well.
It's amazing.
She's incredible.
She's my life.
She's my partner,
she's my soul.
She's my partner.
She's everything to me.
Then you just get sick of each other.
About two,
three years in and then with the seven
year itch,
you know,
that seven year itch starts talking to a
lawyer and she goes,
okay,
listen,
let's just.
If we,
if I get divorced now and then the
lawyer goes,
well,
how much money is he making now?
Does he have any other financial
opportunities that are on the table that
could perhaps increases walt over the
next few years because you might want to
hang in there for a few start thinking
about it.
Mercenary,
like,
like if I just get to 11 years,
if I get to 11 years,
then he gets the CEO position and starts
making x amount of money.
Terrible.
I did have living in a house with a
woman and then she starts hating you or
resenting you at some point and then
starts plotting,
leaving.
We're all just still says living in the
house,
hey honey,
blah blah blah,
and then just just going through the
motions of what a marriage is supposed
to be.
Secretly gonna end it and she kinda
knows exactly what she's going to end
it.
That sounds terrifying.
It's terrifying,
but it's also adorable.
It makes me laugh.
Makes me laugh because it's so silly
because it's such a human thing like
it's not.
It's.
It's such a cultural and a human thing
and it's this weird lottery like this.
The reason why men are attractive to
women at all,
when they're really wealthy,
if they're gross,
gross dude,
like,
who's that guy?
Rupert Murdoch,
the guy who owns Fox.
Yeah.
He's like,
he's old as fuck.
He doesn't take care of his body's kind
of like.
But he's got this hot wife,
right?
There's something.
There's something adorable about that
because this,
this is this weird human folly
thing we got going on.
Security and all that shit.
It's a little bit of that lower empower,
blah blah blah.
But it's also us scam.
And what's interesting is a guy like
that becomes attractive because he's
wealthy and the woman's not wealthy,
right?
You got assume if she's worth a billion
dollars,
he wouldn't be attracted.
She just start fucking her personal
trainer and I'm buying a Ferrari,
honey,
eat mommy's Pissy,
you know,
like that kind of shit.
But if you get to a situation where you
find this old dude and you know,
well,
he's just really kind to me and other
young guys,
they just wanted to have sex and leave
me and he just takes care of me.
And then what does that does that Rupert
Murdoch,
secretary of the Treasury,
Munch and.
Oh yeah,
he's got a banging hot wife.
Yeah,
that's the lady that got in trouble
because she was tweeting about all the
different clothes and things she had on
a,
on a government trip.
She's on a government jet and she's like
tagging all the bag.
She wears the shoes.
She wears it and she's
smoking and he
like.
He looks like her dad easily.
Right.
Doesn't mean for sure he's gross switch.
When you think about how many people
have lost every jobs and money because
of twitter is really fascinating.
I've had a situation happened because of
it,
but nothing.
I haven't done any.
I haven't had a stupid as social media
blow up when you're thinking about how
insane it is with that,
with this is a media where you can
literally control every single word you
say and you still say some wild shit
that costs you millions of dollars,
will cost you relationships
around your friends you don't think
twice about.
And he said it online.
What I was going to say about these rich
women though,
is that like when you're a wealthy man
and the woman's not wealthy,
the fact that you're wealthy is
attractive,
but then if she marries you,
oh,
she's rich to now,
now you're just a dude and now you're
gross,
and now she wants to stay rich.
So she has just kind of hang in there
and are you talking to me out of getting
married,
trying to.
I always tell people
it's one day won't be around one day.
Marriage won't be a thing.
It's going to take time.
You know,
I spend my money on,
I do random,
which I was,
uh,
I was caught in a weird Internet
wormhole last week.
I was a little high and on some adderall
and I clicked on it.
And on adderall or high on adderall,
high on weed and all that.
Jesus,
what's that like?
It's great because it's a,
you have to focus that energy of
adderall,
but the creativity of week,
Ooh,
that's a good Combo,
right?
Like that.
Is that how you write?
I was planning to write,
but I just took some different times on
the internet than I would normally take.
I should have written,
but it's just when you,
when you take adderall,
which is supposed to do is when you take
it,
you're supposed to get settled with what
you want to work on right away and then
when it kicks in,
you focus in on it versus you know,
I think when my shit kicked in,
I was just on the Internet so I just
really dug deep into the Internet.
And so,
uh,
there was this article,
this guy
on this,
this comedian that has all these funny
tweets.
And so I started looking at his tweets.
Yeah.
Good tweets.
And then when his tweet said,
uh,
I'm a,
helped my friend go to wrestling school
and it was just this young woman that
wants to go to restless.
She wants to go to pro wrestling the
scope.
And I went to wwe smackdown a couple of
days prior.
So wrestling was Kinda on my brain.
So she got a go fund me and I just paid
for her wrestling school.
Never met him.
I ain't got no cars,
Joe Hall and we'd just adderall weed and
income and just pay for some random
restless school though.
You just uber everywhere?
Uh,
yeah.
Well I rent cars some places,
but yeah,
when I'm in La,
a uber or lyft around where you live in
Chicago,
I'll get a,
I'll get a rental,
but I'm not there that much.
Even though I,
my residence in Chicago now,
I'm still not going to read a lot.
And so for my own frugality I can't
justify having a car yet.
I am wondering that's an interest in
going to get one.
So I'm a breakout of it.
My Dad is super cheap and so that's just
kinda his brother still.
I'm lightly extravagant and cheap and
practical at the same second extravagant
watch.
What is that?
This is a,
I don't know the name for Berrera.
It's beautiful.
I bought it because I was hyped before I
was a shopping before I did some shows
at radio city with Chappelle and so I
was right before sound check.
I was,
I need to buy a shirt.
I bought a nice shirt and then I'm like,
fuck it.
I'm gonna.
Get a nice watch.
And it wasn't.
It's that,
that crazy.
It was like 700 bucks or some shit.
Yes.
Mr. Bull.
Yeah,
it's a reasonable.
It's too much for a watch,
but not yet
stupid without.
See.
That's the one thing that fucks me up
about watches.
Like if you told me that watch was 10
grand,
I'd be like,
okay.
Like it's the same thing.
Yeah,
it looks like it could be a 10 grand
watch.
Right.
Watches are weird.
Like that was a weird,
but it just kinda pop on stage a little
bit and it's,
you know,
it's a bracelet with the time.
Yeah.
Did you see that floyd mayweather
watched?
We were talking about the La Ferrari.
That's all crystal.
600.
Looks like some futuristic shit.
It looks 600 grand on a lot.
600.
See I could never,
never.
Yeah.
Still even still now when I have this,
I'd be like 700 bucks on this.
Jesus Christ.
Guess what?
You had a book that Gig and Boise to
cover this shit can be doing this gun
ended up on 30 for 30.
Broke that what?
What kind of car are you going to get?
I think I like the Tesla.
Oh,
okay.
Yeah.
To go electric.
Like just if you have to get out of town
quick and there's,
you have to hope that there's
electricity out of town quick.
Yeah.
Like what if some shit goes down like
within some sort of an earthquake or
something?
Uh,
I'll guess I'll just get somebody else's
car.
I mean I've got friends and shit and I'm
sure that'd be leaving.
So
hop a ride.
Yeah.
The thing about Tesla's,
it gets me,
I love them.
I think they're great,
but you really can only drive them 250
miles.
Yeah.
I don't give a fuck what they say.
And even that,
you better be driving slow because if
you're driving fast or if you drive it
in traffic.
Like my business manager came out to
Anaheim for the UFC and he drove from a
Hollywood to Anaheim and his shit was
dead by the time we got to Anaheim.
Oh,
because there's traffic.
Yeah.
So he,
uh,
he was stuck in traffic and it was no
like shit on the,
off the road he had to find a super
station.
So you got to go sit there for a half an
hour at the super station and when you
do that it's fills up to like 75 percent
or something like that.
Oh yeah.
That part's a little bit while
drive it.
No,
maybe I'll get a used car that's
practical for the apocalypse.
Why don't you get like a hybrid,
a lexus hybrid.
Hybrid.
Yeah.
Those are the shit.
And then you can operate.
I think they have a switch where you
could operate.
I know they have that for the Acura Nsx,
that new NSX.
They have an all electric mode where you
could drive a totally electric call.
You hit all the switches and it's
warmer.
Yeah.
Then it's super fast.
Looks fresh.
You know what A.
Yeah.
There you go.
Lexus,
Lexus.
Hybrid,
that's a bad ass car to that coop
because it's um,
it's sporty,
but it's just understated enough where
you're not driving a Ferrari or a
porsche or something like that.
But it's bad ass car.
That one right there.
That.
What does that,
the ls.
Lch.
Yeah.
It's a bad ass car.
Yeah,
baby.
That's what you need to get yourself one
of those.
Look at that thing.
That's slick.
That's pretty slick.
Good looking car.
And you know what I like about lexuses,
man,
they just never break.
I'm,
this is my second lexis that I have
right now and I've never had a single
fucking problem with them.
Those things just never break.
You just drive them.
They never go wrong.
Customer service is fantastic.
They have the best customer service in
any car I've ever had and they're like
deer flashy,
but they're not impressing a rapper,
you know what I mean?
You don't know what type of rapper
though.
Yeah,
that's true,
right?
It was like A.
Yeah,
like de la soul.
They'd probably be impressed
young jeezy by looking at the books.
You know,
I did this week,
I,
uh,
I donated some money to Red Cross for
the Houston thing.
People get mad at you for that and then
I remembered right away about the Red
Cross shit.
It was like a knee jerk donation and
donate to the Houston food bank also.
But then I remembered about the shit
with how they handled the Haiti funds
and Katrina and then I emailed because
it was through Amazon payments.
I was like,
Hey,
uh,
can I get that money back please?
I want to just give it to some other
source.
Oh,
did you really asked?
I haven't got a response,
but it was just a,
it was one of the weirdest.
Now a top 10 weird emails I've sent.
Well,
I asked for a donation back.
Yeah,
that's slippery.
Right.
I wanted back though,
because I don't because they,
uh,
I think it'd be better for some,
some,
uh,
organizations on the ground is one Texas
the Texas diaper because everybody need
diapers and they're based in San
Antonio.
So you can just sit and I just went on
Amazon and just sent a grand worth of
diapers just because that made me feel
good because it's super specific and you
can't really get to fraudulent with
diapers.
That's what I mean.
That's a good way of looking at it.
Like with product you just send the
product.
I mean maybe somebody worst case
scenario somebody steals it,
but for the most part if you send in a
healthful product,
that money,
that shit is getting broken up.
Some of that should go on to the morgue
and some of that shit go to like ink.
Yeah.
It's weird because I guess affective
charities have operating costs.
There's no way to.
People got to get back to.
People have to get paid,
you have to pay for logistics and
planning and and the Red Cross obviously
does a lot of good.
There's no,
no doubt.
They do a lot of good and people just
get mad at the accounting thing.
Like how much of the money goes,
like know on it.
We donated money to the Red Cross for
Harvey,
for Hurricane Harvey and people were
like,
Yo,
the fucking Red Cross a terrible place
to donate money and you want to say
that,
right?
People want to say that?
Yeah.
What is the best thing to donate my.
I'd like to know what the best thing to
donate for.
Like Harvey,
I guess.
Um,
I didn't.
Houston food bank at Texas diaper thing.
Houston food bank sounds like a good a
j.
j watt has one.
The guy he plays for the Houston,
Texas is a few other ones that are on
the ground and in Houston or in
the area where red crosses,
you know,
I mean there obviously I know they have
people on the ground,
but it's pretty general.
So yeah,
they,
they handle a lot of different things,
but they do a lot of good to like,
there's no denying that the Red Cross
does a lot of good,
but it's,
it's that whole accounting thing when
people get mad.
It's funny man,
because there's a lot of people just
waiting to get mad at something.
Even get mad at where you're donating
your money.
Well I think it's just.
I think the issue is that from the
little research I did on it,
that Red Cross hasn't had full
transparency with how I think people
want to know if you give a dollar to Red
Cross,
what percentage goes to this weapon
centers goes to this episode,
this goes to this and I don't think they
offer that and that makes people feel
like they're getting shysters.
Do you think that's because they've been
around so long to like Red Cross has
been around for like how many years ago?
One hundred years.
Probably something.
Right.
And it wasn't until the Internet came
along that these questions even came up,
but that people demanded transparency
probably want to.
I think it's just because they haven't
been that many results from the Haiti
earthquake where people don't see
tangible results.
And I know I donated a bunch on the
phone texting to,
to uh,
you know,
I don't know why clef was doing Red
Cross thing if he was doing something
separate,
but I texted a lot just donate when that
happened.
And so I think it's just when people
don't see results for the money,
it's just like,
you know,
they want to,
especially if you just try to help
something in that,
I think that's what makes it worse for
people where if you try to help and you
donated money to help and you don't
really see the results of it,
then you're like,
what the fuck?
Yeah,
the Haiti things,
it's almost like the infrastructure was
so fucked up and there was so much
damage done down there that you would
need untold billions of dollars to fix
everything.
It's like when you donate millions,
it's like barely even going to see any
results.
Like I wonder how much,
how much damage was actually done to
hate.
You've got to wonder about Houston.
I mean you're talking about Houston
being just catastrophic to the point
where some places are never going to
recover
is uh,
is pretty messed up.
Man.
It's raining right now.
Still raining.
And they were saying how about how the
constant development that they've been
doing there was part of the reason why
the flood,
it hit harder because they developed on
prairie grass,
so certain land where this land might
have soaked up some of that.
I mean we probably would have still
flooded but it might have been less
severe if there wasn't needs because the
next is a new development.
Yeah,
I saw that where they're saying that by
paving over these areas,
those,
those areas can no longer absorb the
water.
But it seems like you're talking about
the.
Did you ever see the graphic that shows
the difference between the amount of
water that rained down on Hurricane
Katrina versus the amount of water that
rained down so far on harvey?
Not even including today.
And it's going to rain apparently
tomorrow too.
I think shit,
it's,
it's so much more water than.
Could you look at the difference for 10
to 15 trillion gallons as of August
28th.
And what is today?
The 29th,
the 30th.
Today's the 30th.
So that's two days ago of rain.
And then Katrina is only six point 5
trillion gallons.
I mean,
that's amazing.
I mean that's A.
I mean I'm sure there's people that
dedicate their lives to this,
but how do you count that they're out
there with scoops?
Measuring is in cubic.
Come on man.
Beyond,
beyond like oil drums.
You really?
Yeah.
Come on.
How many really know?
It definitely looks like a lot and I
hope it seems like a of water is all
right.
Yeah.
Well you know,
one of the things that I love about
tragedies is when people come together
and help each other out and one of the
things is liver is a line of fishing
boats of dudes pulling fishing boats to
go and rescue people.
It was like a whole line on the highway
of dudes with trucks pulling fishing
boats and they were dropping them off
and they were driving their boat rather
ride in their boat down these flooded
roads and rescuing people and bringing
them to safety.
That kind of shit makes me so happy.
That's one of the fucked up things about
people's.
Like sometimes a bad thing makes people
see the good in people.
It makes people do good things,
definitely.
But how,
how insane.
Just the juxtaposition.
Does that have to be to like you and
your crib as watching a show on Sunday,
relaxing,
you know,
frat and then a few days later you have
to be saved by boat
from this,
from this place where you usually just
walk out and get the mail.
You have to.
Somebody has to pull up with a boat.
That's insane.
They said it's okay
once every 500 year storm too.
But how the fuck do they known that 500
years ago people wrote shit down.
Park,
you know,
they,
they showed like raindrops and skulls.
What is that?
People House saved her with a jet ski.
Wow.
Um,
that's is
my friend's grandmother being jet skied
out of her living room in Houston.
What about y'all though?
What A.
Wow.
That house is fucked.
There's a lot of fucked houses.
You other thing about Houston too,
is Houston so damp like Houston in the
summertime,
it's so moist.
That means they're going to have crazy
mold growth there.
Mold is going to be off the charts and
that shit makes people sick as fuck.
Like A.
I've had a friend in Austin,
his whole,
his house had to be gutted because he
was getting sick and they couldn't
figure out what was wrong and they came
in and did some sort of a test of the
air and they're like,
dude,
you're house is infested.
And so they broke down his walls and
apparently there was some pipe leakage
or something inside the wall and then
just the general moisture of the air.
The entire walls were filled with this
black mold and it was getting everybody
sick.
Shit,
that shit is girls.
Yeah,
mold is no,
no joke,
man.
That black mold stuff can really fuck
you up if you're feeling shitty and your
house has mold in it.
You got to do something about that
because there's something going on there
that's a,
you're.
You're literally being poisoned by
house.
Damn.
But Tom Lucas,
dude had that going on too in La.
He had to get his house gutted.
He,
uh,
he was feeling sick for like a year and
then finally did something about it,
found out his house is filled with mold.
They tear it down to the,
to the raw frame of the house and have
to spray everything with this antifungal
shit and Redo the whole house again.
Shit.
How long was he out of the house?
Like over a year.
I want to just says I'm reading a little
article on it says it's a black mold.
Yeah.
It just said it really had his voice
hard,
fucked up his health.
It's no joke,
man.
I mean,
you're,
you're breathing in these little
organisms mean spores are these little.
When you're thinking about mold,
that's a,
like a fungus,
right?
Those wouldn't you consider mold fungus?
Is that what it is?
Yeah,
that shit is in the air and it's
poisoned.
So you're,
you're basically breathing in toxic
poisoned all the time.
Yeah.
That shit is just.
I couldn't imagine this shit man too.
You live in Chicago,
you don't,
you don't care about winners.
It doesn't bother you.
I,
uh,
anywhere I work around it,
work around it.
So a time you like,
yeah,
animals not in town.
Where the.
Well doing gigs in Florida.
So about.
Yeah,
I do,
I book,
I book myself like that during the
winter and in Cali and Arizona,
Texas,
Florida,
etc. And then if I do a run and I'm
scheduled to come back,
but I don't have any actual thing to do
in chicago that I need to be that foot.
I check the weAther at that shit's like
under 25.
Didn't I just chill where I'm at?
I just that look like that's crazy that
I call down to the front desk and say
extended for two days please.
Oh that's a good.
Just hang out wherever you're at.
Just hang out wherever my oh,
go to uh,
some other warm place for a couple of.
That's how,
I mean this is my fIrst time being back
for full winter.
So that was,
that's how I handled it this time where
I would just stay up in the life.
It's nice man.
He lived in a nice loud clap.
I rent my place out.
It's an apartment buildIng.
I read it out when I'm not there.
Oh,
you do?
You're really.
Oh,
you are frugal.
And if people live in your house,
do you know these people know?
Wow.
Airbnb stuff.
Stuff there.
I'm pretty bare bones when I travel and
shit.
Just few t shirts.
Jeans a couple of days.
So your,
your apartment in chicago,
you don't keep a lot of shit there.
I keep just the basic stuff.
Tv and the whatever you need.
If you're a traveling person,
if you be there and then I stayed.
When I get back,
it's three of them I stayed with in
whichever one is open.
I block out a couple of days.
Oh,
you rent,
you have three apartments?
Yeah.
Isn't one building?
Yeah,
that's weird.
Three apartments in one building.
Why did you decide to do that?
Because it was a.
It was.
I mean I got it as an investment
property.
I plan on getting a separate place to
stay yet,
but that's where I stay now is when I'm
there because I'm not that much.
That's just like move.
Do I sound like a weird,
crazy cheap person right now?
You sound.
I wouldn't say cheap because you do have
a $700 watch.
I would say frugal.
Frugal is the
right way to approach this.
Yeah.
Why not?
I mean,
having them sitting around not
generating any income doesn't do anybody
any good.
Absolutely not.
I think it was driving me crazy.
Yeah.
So you're doing the right thing is a
man.
I was at a festival called afro punk,
a music festival,
uh,
and it's,
it's just a beautiful vessel.
Was a all black artists and it's great
and people dress up in the wildest
outfit.
It was a fun time and met the people
that put it on.
I met them a few years back.
they used to come to my show at knitting
factory in brooklyn.
Jaseline in matthew dope people is so
backstage a cello.
And I was there with a friend.
Somebody introduced me to this lady.
She says,
oh,
I uh,
she asked a industry job,
oh,
I work here and blah blah blah.
We love to have you in.
And I say,
sure,
you know,
that sounds,
that sounds good.
I'd like to do.
it sounded like an interesting thing to
do and so she hands me her phone and I
put in my email and my assistant's email
and then give her the phone baCk and she
was like,
you gotta go give your number though.
I'll take that as a sign of disrespect.
I'm an oji in this game.
And I was,
I was super high at this point and I was
like,
what Is happening right now?
She took it as a sign of disrespect that
you didn't give her your number because
I guess he deals with lots of famous
people or some shit.
So the fact that I just gave her emails,
she just,
I'd never met them.
I met this woman a 90 seconds prior to
this part of the inner.
It was so
yeah,
I was so high to where is this really
happening right now?
I really wanted to work with you and I
just gave you
the info to get in touch with me.
Yeah.
Why do we have to talk on the phone?
That's less effect.
It was suit.
And so I'm like,
what is that?
And then,
so,
uh,
and it's so
goes on about that,
but with the antibiotic for how long
that long,
but then she tried to continue the
conversation after.
It's obvious that her vibe haS changed.
When I was in,
she went from,
hey,
was that enough today to a very dry.
Oh,
so,
oh,
she continued the conversation.
That's not good in this kind of drive.
Weird,
wet what she said,
oh,
so you're about to go on this tour with
nas and lauryn hill,
how do you approach the shows
differently?
But it's obvious that she just kind of
asking them so that you,
you.
And so I was.
So I didn't,
I answered it and then she pulls out her
phone and she was like,
oh my friends over there.
And then,
uh,
she,
she like goes like this,
him.
And then I'll just said,
all right,
I'm outta here.
I just walked off somewhere else.
But then it was such a weird experience
that the comedian in me was hoping she
was doing some weird andy kaufman bit
because that intense,
it was just super weird because
everybody was.
EveryboDy else was really chill.
I,
I wasn't even having any network and
discussions with people like that there
and everybody else was really chill.
I don't lIke talking to other people
that did that really happen.
And so I saw her later,
like a couple of hours later I said was
well you doing a bit.
Was that again?
And then she tried to play it like she
will,
but I could tell she was like,
I had to check,
you check me for what?
And so,
but she was really into collecting
people.
That's what she's really also,
she was a interacted with me based on
who else she's dealt with in her past
versus just interacted with me as an
individual.
So she was just super salty and I was
just so ironic that at this beautiful
black festival,
the only person beIng weird backstage is
a white woman in her forties.
Taking that as a sign of disrespect.
It was crazy and you must've felt like
as soon as she said that like,
oh,
this,
this definitely was the right move.
Not to give you my number because you're
fucking crazy.
Yeah.
It was just more like I was wondering
now then after I was like,
it was mine
because sometimes I give,
I give random people my number out,
have like random I've given,
but I don't know what.
I don't know.
Maybe something that instinct,
he knew it just gave it to her,
but I've given people in my email before
too,
but it was just,
it was just.
Especially since I was super high,
I was like,
well see the thing is for business
though,
email's the best way to contact people
because you can 100 percent or you can
email somebody at three in the morning.
It's nothing.
Well,
yeah.
Not only that you can like if you say,
hey,
we're trying to work out the logistics
for this thing in february between
February 2nd and fourth,
tell us your availabilities so then you
can sit in front of a computer and look
at my calendar first.
My birthday.
Happy birthday.
Thanks.
Look at that shit and you can go,
oh,
okay,
well here's what I've got and you could
we.
It's,
it's clear.
It's more having a conversation over the
phone that I got to remember.
I've got to write it down.
Hold on.
Let me get a piece of paper or let me
dictate it into my phone.
Like that's less effective.
Especially.
It was fucking bitch,
but it's a crazy man.
It's crazy people out there,
man.
I've,
I've met men and women that do that.
They want your number.
Then if you don't want to give him your
number,
they get upset.
Well,
the reason why you're getting upset is
the very reason why I don't want to get
my number.
I don't want as we live.
Yeah.
You too excited about getting my number.
Someone's got excited about getting your
number.
You shouldn't give them your number.
Yeah,
she started name dropping and shit.
Fuck that.
As soon
as they start.
Name dropping out a second time.
I've done stuff.
I'm putting on events for obama.
Yes.
Call obama right now.
Wake him up.
That's cool.
That's really great.
Did you did that?
But donald pence for obama,
dId obama give you his number?
Crazy asshole like obama's given out.
Hey,
text me anytime.
No matter what's going on with the 7
billion people in the world that I'm
handling.
Yeah.
Well maybe she's a troll and she knew
that she was becoming a podcast story.
Is she that I like to make people.
Sometimes I like to make people more
calculated than they are.
That's like some illuminati shit that's
like.
I don't think so.
I think she's just crazy lady.
Just a weird show.
Business lady,
you know,
just a crazy lady.
Have you completely.
We moved past all the cosby shit or do
you still take grief for that?
That grief?
No,
I've uh.
Well now you're vindicated.
I was sort of a grief.
It was just where I would,
uh,
before to talk about it in situations I,
they want to.
And also it came out
the joke,
uh,
and that video came out right before we
were starting the rollout for my comedy
central tv show.
And we actually people on,
we pushed back my announcement because
they're looking opportunist.
That news was that crazy that we pushed
It back by.
Maybe he pushed it back,
the premier announced by a month or two
because it was that and so,
so even though I had my comedy central
deal in place this since 2012,
I had an all around comedy central deal
is.
So then when that came out and then I
got my show with,
well then my show was scheduled to go on
the air.
It looked like,
oh,
he did the cosmic joke and then he got a
tv show.
It's like,
no man,
this is like my fourth development deal
and this is finally to show that I got.
Isn't that funny how things work here?
But.
So that was,
that was the thing where instead of,
uh,
instead of just having this show that I
was able to,
it was this energy around it,
you know,
and 2005 july or early 2005.
It was this energy around it where if I
was going to do press around that time,
they were definitely gonna.
What year was it?
This was 2015.
Two years ago.
Two thousand five.
Sorry.
Yeah,
2015,
uh,
and uh,
that show in philly was October,
2014,
so yeah,
it just kind of really affected the
energy around it and as far and,
and my m one and an eagerness to do a
lot of press just because I knew it was
going to come up and I was just like,
I was so uh,
that was that.
I'm not saying that that's the reason my
show's not on anymore at all.
Excuse me,
for people like your show sucks.
that's why I
like doing the show.
I did,
I did like aspects of it.
I liked the activity part of it was
always something to do,
you know what I mean?
If you like,
if you,
you face up to show you gotta write,
you gotta edit,
you got to get the writers to do stuff.
You got to um,
you know,
deal with costumes and it's always a
task to do.
So.
I like just the,
that I know for that whatever,
what,
four months,
three,
four month period.
I was never bored during that time
doing.
When I do movies,
I'm hellebore yeah,
I was like movie just because it's no
use.
Just sit arOund and you go say some
stuff.
It's like baseball.
It's baseball.
It's absolutely baseball.
If you talk about a 12 hour day that you
spend on a movie,
shoot is actually for me,
45 minutes,
an hour of actual acting and shit and I
mean with me maybe 10 minutes of actual
acting because I'm not a good actor at
all.
I'm just saying words,
but yeah,
it's just shit.
It's just mind numbingly boring.
But the finished product,
the finished product is,
it's cool to see and it's dope to be a
product,
but we're doing it.
The director has a lot to,
you know,
he's moving around and he got a lot of
shit to do and so he might yet.
But uh,
yeah,
doing that shit.
It's boring.
It's very boring.
There's no other way to do it though.
It seems like it's always that way.
Uh,
I think it depends on the budget of it.
When they got money to burn,
then they got time to burn also doing an
indie movie,
then they ain't going to keep it going.
Gonna keep that shit moving.
But then yeah,
if you're doing a at this one movie band
of robbers that's on netflix and it was
Just,
you know,
we were active.
What is that?
It's a uh,
it's time sawyer and huckleberry finn,
but in real,
in real time,
like in current time.
Uh,
yeah.
So I did that and that was,
it played a few scenes in that,
but it was quick.
It was no wasted days.
You know,
sometimes you go to a movie set.
They were like,
yeah,
get here at 9:00 in the morning.
You get there,
go through the whole shit,
get your hair,
make up,
get your clothes on and sit around and
just sit for a full.
I sat for four days
full days and then do like,
what was the,
what the fuck was the plan?
They want you there in case they get
through a scene,
we move onto the next one.
Not even anything.
When you were like,
no,
we're not gonna you not know.
Do you good for the day?
For the whole,
for the whole day.
Who planned this out
now when you were doing a tv show?
How many months ago?
You said it for like four months.
Uh,
eight episodes.
So it's two months of shooting and then
a month or a couple months of pre.
Pro?
Yeah.
And do you,
you enjoyed it?
I did enjoy.
I Just,
yeah,
I enjoy it.
I want to do a.
I'll probably do something on tv next
year again to a show once I get the idea
right and figure out exactly.
You think you'd do comedy central comedy
central needs to show a.
They need something.
I do somewhere I'm going to.
Do you know what the best choices.
I had a good relationship over there
still.
Um,
but we'll see.
We'll see what it is.
It's so hard to do those things because
you got to deal with so many other
people.
Get so many different cooks in the
kitchen.
Executives,
all these different people hanging out.
Well part.
I mean they will,
they will pretty chill.
They were,
they would,
it was,
it will be weird aspects and just weird
things that you think you care about
this.
It'll be a weird line,
like why don't you give a shit about
this line so much,
but they'll let other shit go,
but he'll sometimes give notes on
something that a st pretty insignificant
to me.
Yeah,
I think a lot of times they just want to
justify their existence.
They want to justify their paycheck and
have some sort of point of view.
Even if it doesn't make any sense,
they just want to add to it.
Yeah,
tweak it a little bit.
That was my idea when I guess he took
his hat off and made it a little nod.
That was my idea.
Yeah.
conference calls is because everybody
feels the need to chime in on the call.
I've been on conference and I'm like,
why am I
on this?
This?
I don't know if I've had a.
I don't know if I had a conference call
where it just felt really good.
F,
like website.
That was a good conference call.
I'm glad I did that shit.
Never had a conference call one time I
canceled the show.
I was supposed to do a,
um,
a comedy central standup special under
the old regime and um,
we had a conference call and they went,
they had like a transcript of my set and
they were going over the material and
they're like,
well,
you definitely can't talk about this in
you.
You can'T say this.
and you can say we got like five minutes
into the conversation.
I go,
stop,
stop.
I'm out.
Go am I doing this?
And they went,
what?
I go and I'm not doing this.
I don't want to do this.
Like there's no way I go,
you guys are butcher and everythIng.
I go,
this is my ass.
You know what my act is?
You want to cut things out and change
things and you like,
there's no way this is not happening.
Yeah.
So thank you though.
Appreciate it.
And they did.
They did.
They were stunned.
There was a,
it was one of those stun conversations.
Like what?
I was like,
yeah,
I'm not doing this.
Did they?
Did they flip though?
No,
no,
it was just a straight up.
Well,
I,
yeah,
I was like,
we'll go on somewhere else.
I'm like,
this is crazy.
Because one of those conversations were
there.
It'd been,
there were super resistant to
controversial shit.
This is a,
this is what,
a few years back.
Like I wish I could remember late
nineties.
No,
no,
2005 ish.
Six ish.
I winded up doing actually a series a.
I'm a,
I'm a special on netflix that went to
showtime.
That was 2005,
so that's where I wound up doing it.
but the conversation on the phone was
just like,
what they were going over the material.
No.
Okay.
We're gonna have issue with this.
You can't say that.
He definitely can't say this.
I'm sorry.
This is just those doing those specials
on tv.
It's such a bad idea anyway because
they're always all broken up.
Yeah,
yeah.
It's,
yeah,
it's especially for stories.
I did my first two with comedy central
and they were,
they break up your store and you broke
up a story.
longest story and my second one,
if I'm not mistaken,
but they all netflix now and they're
full,
but yeah,
they would.
I mean they got a.
That's how they paid me is that they
fucking cell bodies pray.
I got to take another piSs real quick.
Too much water to drink.
Four bottles of water.
You might be the new water champ.
I'm not going to sit outside to austin.
It is 110.
Yeah,
it's crazy hot here too.
It's so hot that I went running and it
was burning the bottom of my feet
through those five finger shoes.
You know?
I wear those really thin trail running
shoes.
Those vibrams that everybody tells me
he's gonna.
Kill me.
People hack like you're gonna die.
If you were.
Those things look way I tell people,
I'm like,
dude,
you a class action lawsuit.
Eastern studies are terrible for you
bro.
They're not.
It's just your body is used to wearing a
cast on your feet.
Listen to everybody that's worried about
those things.
I swear If you just use those things and
walk for awhile and then like where I'm
a little bit and then eventually build
up to running with them,
you'll be fine,
but you have to strengthen your feet.
I'm neil brennan said he got plantar
fasciitis from running on a treadmill.
what those things on those vibram
fivefIngers shoes.
Yeah.
Those are the ones that really stick to
your feet.
Toe shoes.
Yeah.
I run with those and they're better for
your feet.
It's like your.
Your foot has to be strong because most
of the time when you're running,
you're running with running shoes on
like have you seen the average pair of
running shoes?
They have a thick heel and what happened
is nike.
I think in the seventies whenever they
came out with these things,
they literally changed the way people
run because people started running in,
landing with their heel because that's
where the big cushion is changed the
gate,
the natural human gate and to put way
more pressure on your knees and people
started developing all these issues
because of that.
The real way to run.
It's supposed to.
You're supposed to run on the forefoot
like landing on the ball of the foot and
let the natural structure of your foot
decelerate your stride.
That's what you're supposed to do,
but most people's feet are not
conditioned for that because we wear
these thick ass sneakers everywhere and
those things act as it's like wearing a
cast everywhere.
That's how it's been described to me.
So over the last four or five months
I've been running with what they call
minimal issues,
so there's almost no cushioning.
It all.
It's very thin and I was saying that
it's so hot out that it was running in
these things and the bottom of my feet
got hot from the just from running on
the ground.
The ground was so hot.
It was it starting to melt or something.
Today I could feel that I could feel the
heat through the bottom of my feet was
hurting.
It is actually like burning the bottom
of my foot,
which by the way,
people,
if you have dogs,
be super fucking careful.
Your dogs outside because you're walking
your dog on concrete.
You could easily burn the shit out of
your dog's paws.
Just the other day.
I just had looked a little bit into it.
Uh,
the painting,
different sections of a asphalt I guess
here with,
I don't know if it's like white.
Yeah.
So It's a heat absorbing color instead
of black asphalt.
Black asphalt apparently just absorbs
the heat and reflects the heat.
Radiates it around.
Yeah.
This is,
was dropping like 10 to 15 degrees
almost immediately.
I was her here.
You got 12 degrees just after one coat.
YeaH,
I've seen that.
That's amazing.
That's great.
And all that as hard as I saw in one
article,
but it's like 120 degrees.
It was getting some places like off
sunset boulevard and la,
like just in the middle of the day when
it's like 85 outside,
90 degrees outside.
Makes sense.
Really,
really extra hot.
Yeah,
it totally makes sense.
Yeah.
In all of la is asphalt basically to
paint that shit stupid.
Yeah.
This would change maybe maybe a little
bit on your feet.
Oh yeah.
But you run it on
running on dirt.
So I'm running up hills,
but uh,
it was so hot.
It was the first time it's ever like,
burned the bottom of my feet.
Like I could feel it.
It was hot.
I was like,
jesus,
I'm not a uh,
I don't really jog,
but I'm a good judge of form.
Are you?
I just like a running coach now know if
I could coach,
but I could just,
I could definitely tell you when you're
wrong because I see some people like to
heavy footed,
heavy footage,
bad when most people are running on
their heels.
I see people running and I'm like,
wow.
It's crazy.
When you look around to you look around
how many people are wearing shoes with
elevated heels?
You're like,
wow,
that's kinda nuts.
It's kind of not telling me people just
got accustomed to wearing those kinds of
sneakers and running
people are running basketball shoes or
something too.
That's lIke,
you probably shouldn't be doing that.
I think you'd be better off with that.
Then you are with running shoes.
Just don't land that way.
Just to land on your heel.
If you went to the ball of your feet
basketball shoes,
I think she'd be fine,
but what the fuck do I know?
But you know,
I'm running with some really.
I run all knee with those.
A five finger shoes now or with um,
I wear these morels too.
They're called vapor or something or
like the real thin,
too minimalist.
Do people ever try to read it?
But people probably still will attempt
to stop you while you jog,
right?
Yeah.
But I don't do,
you can't.
That's so crazy.
Like I'm in the middle.
You're literally going to interrupt a
workout.
Looks like I've had people come up to me
while I'm on the treadmill before,
like,
hey man,
can I get you?
I get a photo with you.
like definitely not.
Now people do it.
If you can have a mouthful of food,
you could be eating food.
I was cutting food up for my daughter
and this lady asked me for a picture.
I was like,
are you crazy?
I'm feeding my kid.
Like,
this is just.
People just don't give a fuck.
They want to adorn their facebook with
something that they saw on tv once.
It's weird.
Not even printing it up.
They don't care.
Not even really pregnant usually.
Well,
they don't even want it that much.
It's just like they have a phone and
like.
It's like if you have a gun,
you want to pull the trigger.
YOu have a phone and you want to take a
picture like how many people do you see
at the 4th of July?
Taking videos of fireworks.
You are never going to watch that
fucking video.
Who the hell is going to watch a
fireworks video like how sad is your
life?
Have to get where you all have anything
better to do than be sitting there
watching little lights go off on your
foreign screen.
Hey man,
airport layoffs are real dog.
Is that what you do when you're sitting
there?
LaYover.
You know the person that did it.
You know when you like.
Say you got to lay over in salt lake
city.
You delayed by five hours to go through
your videos and delete all the fireworks
once that's clean up.
Yeah.
You're eating up a lot of gigabytes.
You are.
When you look at it,
you realize how much bullshit as you put
shit in the cloud.
Yeah.
DO you do?
I shouldn't know.
I know even when I do it,
but it's nothing too,
too risque.
There's a couple risks,
but my face isn't in there.
That's one thing that's just,
you
know,
face.
Would you,
uh,
I think I asked a friend this yesterday.
What would you like,
let's say amazon started a g-mail
competitor.
Would you just like,
not just jump over,
but like wouldn't it be a good thing
maybe to just start fresh with all your
email and be like,
eh,
what do I need that's 20 years old in my
emr,
15 years old?
Oh yeah,
for sure.
I don't want it.
I want to see it.
Definitely.
If I look at my email on a daily basis,
nine out of 10 things,
I get her bullshit.
Nine out of 10,
one out of 10 I need.
and those people,
I would just give my new email address
anyway,
like already did that pretty recently
are just changed his email.
I'm like,
it's good.
Move,
uh,
chAnge your phone.
I changed my phone.
That's a good move to having more than
one phone is a good move to having a
phone for people like that fucking lady
at that thing was your number.
Okay.
I don't know that number by heart.
I just remembered my number right now by
heart and I'm about to change it again.
Yeah.
Just I liked not knowing until I don't
care as you know,
what else I'd like to.
I liked that my vision is going so I
can't read things.
So like when,
uh,
when I,
if I get like an email or something like
that,
like I can go.
What does it say?
Uh,
okay.
I don't feel held to like read the
whole.
I don't feel compelled to put my reading
glasses and go into depth.
I just look at it too.
Quick glance.
Don't need to pay attention to this as
some bullshit.
Yeah.
Think about some important things.
That's,
that's a,
that's like old man and flaky.
See that shit.
What's that fucking newspaper?
Damn game on?
yeah.
I don't give a fuck.
I'm practicing not giving a fuck.
I've always been good at it,
but I'm like actively working on it
harder and harder more now than ever.
It's tough,
especially if you're in you're thinking
about is tough nuts to not give a fuck,
but also be very aware of thinking about
the audit time where you have to you if
you saying you don't give a fuck,
you do give a fuck.
[inaudible] you making the choice to be
like,
I don't give a fuck,
but you still do give a fuck.
You just like,
I'm not going to react in a way as
somebody who gives a fuck,
but I give a fuck.
Yeah.
Making a choice though.
You know what it's like.
It's like I'm pretending I don't give a
fuck by saying I don't give a fuck.
Yeah.
I'm like putting that out there.
I'm like making a conscious decision to
not give a fuck,
but in doing so I'm giving a fuck about
not giving a fuck.
Yes means you give a fuck.
You know who don't give a fuck who
locksmiths wise that they don't get
locksmith confidence stop.
Why don't think of it?
Because they can open any door.
Because they can open any door and you
called them about the laW.
I mean,
I guess they have to eyeball it and see
what it is,
but I call it like I've had.
I wAs locked out of my In new yoRk and
I'll say,
uh,
come through and tell them that I'll Be
there iN five minutes.
Once the price,
I'll let you know when I'm there.
Like,
that's confidence,
right?
I'm gonna tell you when I'm there
Because you need to get into your place.
That's true.
And yeah.
And so I've,
I've,
uh,
I've sent locksmiths away just as an
actor,
too much money,
just as an act of aggression.
Yeah.
When he was like,
it's this much.
And I was like trying to talk him down
and he wasn't having it and he was like,
so and I was like,
it's fine.
It'S all good.
And I just sat in my hallway foot.
I think I went to the bar a couple of
doors down just called another
locksmith.
How much did you save?
Not worth that time.
It was good for my spirit.
Now
did you get a vibe off that dude?
Like you sort of,
you had a vibe off that lady didn't want
to give her your number.
There's lIke a five.
I just,
I think it's just a,
cause I've,
I just see how quick they can do it and
I'm like,
I could do that in,
you know,
like they,
they do it in maybe 20,
30 seconds sometimes and I'm like I can
learn how to do it in the five minute
version of that,
how fast they do it and so it makes me,
when I see how they do it and it pisses
me off to know that he can just break in
my shit at anytime and that he's just
charging
me an arbitrary price because this
market is kinda,
you know,
all over the place.
Yeah.
Well I guess they have a skill and
should get paid for that.
Absolutely.
Right.
So like what,
do you remember how much money?
It was
a hundred 50,
let's say a hundred 50.
Oh,
how to just give him the money.
I don't.
I'm
probably.
Yeah,
but you like,
like you,
you,
you gotta enjoyment out of saying no.
Yeah,
because I think he,
yeah,
I think he's used to mfa would be like
short and I'm like,
you,
well,
you know what,
you got this skill,
you can break into people's houses and
shit.
I've seen people do this shit fast and I
don't,
I'm not having it live on a block.
I didn't want a black widow,
but I'm not in a suburban area.
My block in,
uh,
in brooklyn and williamsburg,
I got one of the most lit blocks in this
shit to do.
It's Just,
yeah,
it's like four bars just on my very
block.
Oh,
I got time to kill.
went down to my local and a play some
skeeball hung out.
Yeah.
Well now how much did you offer to take
off?
I don't remember the specifics of the
negotiation,
but it was a very nominal amount.
He bought me nothing.
Yeah.
And he wasn't really budget and shit.
Yeah,
it was Just,
yeah,
insight into the mind of hannibal
burress.
That's how my dad was.
Three apartments,
rent them out with the airbnb,
$700 watch.
Big spend.
No car,
no car won't pay for a locksmith,
will pay for a locksmith.
Did pay for a lot,
but not that one.
Not that one.
Yeah.
How much do you think you saved on the
second locksmith?
Macho man,
but drake money and had some drinks at
that bar.
Twenty to 30 bucks.
Yeah.
I kicked in my door once,
didn't have my lock,
did not my key.
Will you with the family?
It was just,
you know,
I was by myself when I was a was pre
cell phone days.
oh,
okay.
I thought front kick the shit out of
that door and call the dude.
yeah.
It was like,
what happened?
I was like,
yeah,
I didn't have my key.
I had to fix the door jam the whole day.
That,
that little metal thing,
that.
The thing that waS all bent and fucked
up.
It's amazing how easy it is to kick open
the door.
Like when you see those dudes banging
their shoulder against the door.
If you've got a solid front kick,
there's no way that door survives.
They just open you.
Unless it's a pull for you door.
If it's a pull forward toward here,
fucked like you got to be able to kick
through the door or you have a hard kick
butt at a push open door.
Super easy.
They just open up,
you know,
you said she was solo solo when you did
it,
but the,
I just still have a locked image of your
family with you while you pick up to the
door.
And the kids like,
well if they were crying,
they were Crying.
I would.
I kicked open the door once on a set of
news radio and we blamed on the band
anthrax.
Oh,
it wasn't,
it wasn't part of a scene.
It was just,
it was a door to the break room.
We were drunk and uh,
I was with uh,
maura maura tierney and she was like,
god,
I'm fucking hungry.
I want to get in that break room.
And I'm like,
I can get in that door.
And she's like,
how are you getting in the door?
I go,
I'd have to kick it open.
She goes,
you can kick open that door.
I go,
yeah.
And she goes into it like,
all right,
here we go.
Boom.
I just kicked the shit out of that door
and it bent the fucking all the shit
that like works inside the door.
Yeah.
And then.
But it was so worth it.
Is this very shady though to blame it
on?
That band was wrong.
They weren't.
They were working on the set that week.
They were on the episode with us
to this day.
Is this an nbc universal?
I think we're on sunset gower at the
time,
I think.
Yeah,
I just stopped the whole net door.
It was a big old metal door to.
Did you use to add those guys?
Sometimes you need to do some scenes
drunk.
No,
no.
This was after the episode.
It had been done.
So pixilated is that?
Yeah,
that's them on the derrick.
Cool guys though.
I hope a production didn't call them
because we just were like,
who?
They were like,
who fucked up the door.
LIke who knows?
And they're like probably that fucking
band.
Like hm.
Probably
I would guess it was that band
fucked up a door for like $10 in potato
chips.
Yeah.
I was wondering what the,
what the take was just not much.
Just some chips,
snack foods,
whatever was available.
Good in the moment.
Oh,
did this.
To be able to do that?
Feels amazing.
Yeah.
To be able to kick a door open.
My buddy as our gave me this tip about,
uh,
like when he goes to the movies,
he's ordered as a kid's ticket and
because the people taking the tickets,
they don't look really.
They just look at the theater number and
a movie.
Right.
And what I did it the first time it was
two tickets,
are you saving for bucks or whatever for
some change.
BuT it felt amazing.
It felt like it felt like I'm in any
heist,
you know,
it felt really good.
It's like,
yeah.
It's like don't look,
don't look.
Yeah.
The girl didn't want to do that shit.
She was like,
why are you doing that?
So you're with a girl,
you
can't do that with a girl.
Yes.
You can just show them who you are.
This is me,
I am unreasonably cheap.
This is who I am seeing a moVie
together,
setting the stage two.
So like when that prenup come,
she understands she's not going to go.
I can't believe you brought a prenup.
Yeah.
She was like,
of course,
you know me,
I cheated them.
Any theater to pretend to be a kid for
four bucks.
Exactly.
But that four bucks that sending you,
you know,
since your brain into a great place,
a lot of women really get upset by it.
But cheapness,
yo,
I,
uh,
I was actually,
I was out with this girl in and
we,
uh,
we went to this club,
she was driving and we parked in this
parking lot.
It's like one of those situations where
you park in a parking lot.
It was a dentist office,
but now somebody is charging for it.
And so my Immediate question,
like five bucks for the parking spot.
Right.
But my immediate question is,
does he,
is it,
do they have a deal with this dentist
office or do they just charge at night
for people to park in his dentist off?
Because you're not the dentist.
Why can you come up?
And I was telling him,
I'm like,
yo,
I told her that I was going to say that
before we got out the car.
I was like,
I'm gonna.
Ask him if he's a dentist.
I'm not gone.
And she was like,
and then we'd get out.
You're not the dentist.
She was like,
what the fuck is calling?
She was upset that you actually did it.
Yeah.
And so I was really about,
it'd be like,
what?
Like what's the chances of it getting
told like I was really not because of
the,
I think the cheapest was a part of it,
but it was genuinely I wanted to know
the reality of the situation.
Right.
And did they explain to,
you know,
I just,
she was getting upset and I just paid
the $5.
She got real upset.
Not upset,
but enough where she wasn't.
We didn't have the same sense of humor
and a frugality,
whereas she,
we weren't on the same wavelength as far
as that interaction.
So she wasn't rolling with me.
That trumps a lot of women crazy.
Find out that you cheap.
Yeah.
It was supposed to be bold,
like that's one thing that women like
that I feel like when dudes make it
rain,
right.
You throw in a bunch of money in the
air,
you don't give a fuck.
There's something about that that like,
it's exciting coming up out that
strippers like that,
but the average women won't like that.
Right.
That's true.
It's,
but it's a male move.
Talk to make it rain as trip couples a
total mail move.
Right.
It's a saying that you don't give a fuck
about money.
It's chuck it up in the air.
I mean,
there's a lot behInd that.
I haven't bought out in the strip club
like that,
but I think the most I've spent in the
night in the strip club is maybe 800,
something like that.
Uh,
Which in atlanta is.
I spent two months In atlanta this
summer.
That's pretty low.
You know,
there's some guys that go and just have
10,
10 grants such and such.
This rapper spent 20 grand in the strip
club,
which is,
it's shocking and frightening to me.
Uh,
yeah.
Lana is famous for that,
right?
Yeah.
It's great.
Strip clubs in atlanta.
I was just there.
I was there friday.
I was at the tabernacle.
Yeah.
It's a fun time,
man.
City man.
It's a city.
It's a,
it's a,
it's a good night life.
And,
but yet the strip club where it says
it's a spectacle,
you know what I mean?
So you just.
I mean it's fun,
but I went there a few times.
Who's throwing money?
Who's at a 21?
Savage.
It's 21 savage,
young thug.
They are on a stage.
Maybe they did a song or something,
but it's just
a throw money on everybody.
See it says.
But that is a thing like the flamboyance
of not worrying at all about grinding to
the point where you just throw it up in
the air.
Yeah,
it was a boxing girl with that.
mIght be,
that might be king of diamonds.
You don't want them.
Me on paper.
I said atlanta because atlanta up
around.
Uh,
yeah.
It's some of the strip clubs.
They have girls boxing and king of
diamonds in miami.
I went there once on a monday.
They have girls boxing.
It's a huge strip club.
I don't like my strip clubs used it over
with,
I like my strip clubs,
kinda like dive bars,
like a certain strip clubs.
If you walk in and you throw up a couple
hundred dollars,
like you can kind of take over the
energy of the place.
Uh,
like all the strippers and started
coming to you and shit had a small point
at a smaller place.
King of diamonds.
That's where rIck ross hangs out like
that.
Yeah.
Mayweather through something.
Then I can see that chemo,
diamonds and it has a basketball court.
I think we talked about strip clubs last
time we were here doing happened.
Uh,
when they have a basketball court in
there.
and a barber shop in the strip club.
Yeah,
a barbershop and a basketball court.
Why they have a basketball court?
Because sometimes before you want to
just get your endorphins going before
you throw out of money,
I guess.
Or maybe the strippers like to play
basketball.
I don't know.
Weird.
Interesting.
But it's a.
The music is great.
That's a weird strip cup too because the
girls were close.
What's going on?
I think this is the preamble.
This is the youtube version.
To get them warmed up.
You want to go to vimeo?
You can see the,
uh,
the real deal.
Oh,
does vimeo show nudity?
Yeah.
No,
it's interesting.
What's the rules with twitter?
Because I follow some porn stars.
Yeah,
they,
they show full on fucking,
uh,
I think that's it.
You could do it.
That's amazing.
Sometimes I forget that I followed
pornhub on twitter
and then I'll be scrolling through and
it's just a gift of some,
just some part,
but.
Oh yeah.
Well,
it's a real
problem.
If yOu leave your phone around,
your kids grab it when they scroll
through your feed,
like,
hey,
throw,
scroll through the home,
feed
it.
Got it.
I mean they to see it somehow.
Just one of those animated gif files,
15 seconds of acid deck.
Woo.
It's amazing that they can have that on
twitter with the millions and millions
and millions of like,
that doesn't bother them.
I mean there's worse things on twitter.
president.
What
did you see that,
that woman,
valerie,
I don't know how you say her name is
valerie plam or plume.
Something like that.
she's the cia operative that was outed
by,
I guess it was dick cheney,
I think.
Um,
it was a big deal,
like a because he had said something or
husband had said some things that dick
cheney out at her and it like
compromised her position and compromise
the mission she was working on.
Anyway,
she's working now on buying twitter to
kick Donald Trump off.
Valerie p l a m e n I do not know how to
say no.
She's crowdfunding to buy twitter to
kickoff Donald Trump.
She wants to buy twitter just so they
could kick billion dollar goal.
She made 85 grand so far by the law.
I got news for you,
honey.
Twitter is not for sale for a billion
dollars at twitter for a billion dollar.
That's nice.
Come back when you've got about $7
billion out of him.
Valerie,
give that money to houston.
Fuck outta here.
That'll make it.
How much money do you think?
Like how much moneY is twitter worth?
Like if twitter was going to be for
sale,
it had to be for sale first.
He would have to be lIke $15 billion.
Right.
Insane potential.
But yeah,
this is the thing with twitter from the
little bit that I know is that it in
comparison to the other social medias,
they've had travel.
Monetize.
Yeah.
In,
uh,
in the same way.
So like instagram is making money.
Facebook obviously making money and his
whole body up.
Snapchat is doing what twitter hasn't
figured out how to get real revenue,
like people use twitter and,
and are active on it and live tweet
events.
But as far as the money,
it hasn't been.
It's been lagging
in comparison.
Do you understand that?
It doesn't make sense to me.
Like,
like instagram has sponsored tweets with
that saY,
what are you putting up there?
The market value of 15 point 7 billion
for twitter a year ago.
Yeah.
So why is that?
Chick thinks she can get it for a
billion bucks.
She's tripping.
She's just trying to get attention,
right?
Yeah.
actually smoke.
Well,
you think it's just,
that's just pure,
just anger to come up with anger because
anger at not just to have the initial
weirdo wackadoodle not going to happen.
I did,
buT because I've had a lot of those
didn't calm down.
Yeah.
So to go through somebody like fucking
do a crowdfunding twitter that's so
stupid.
and then to actually like go onto the
site and then write it up.
Yeah,
put your picture up there.
Yeah.
And then look at it proofread and go
through all that shit and still be like,
yeah,
still crowdfund for twitter.
Still be on board with the idea and post
just,
it's so stupid because there's 350
million people in this country.
if every single person what's mesh?
She just wants to become the largest
shareholder so she can make the
decision.
Oh.
Which is why the fuck would anybody give
her that money?
You're giving her that money.
like if you gave her 100 grand,
how do you.
Does she give you an accounting form of
what she's doing with that 100 grand?
That's so stupid.
No one's going to die.
I can't believe she got 85 grand.
That's amazing in and of itself.
Well,
the final number at the end,
the end of that number is seven,
which means somebody gave like $2 or
one.
Somebody gave a weird off.
Now
I don't have much,
but good luck.
yeah.
Who's going to give more than five
bucks?
Let's look at it.
Eight because sometimes they show the
names of people that,
that gave stuff and like what they,
uh,
what they said.
And so let's just see victoria needs.
Let's do this now.
And what else?
Uh,
no.
the way he tweets,
like get this out of office and put them
weight can cause damage.
$5.
Look at that
tweet that he made.
Look at the tweets.
Crawled back up jamie to where it was
before.
So you could see trump's tweet.
We'll get that military solutions and
now fully in place.
No po,
no pay space between comma and locked.
So typos galore.
Locked and loaded.
No comma,
no space again.
Should North Korea act unwisely?
And then douBle space the fuck that's
about hopefully kim jong un.
We'll find another path.
Exclamation point.
It's just like,
it's like you took some housewife from
middle of nowhere and allowed her to be
president.
I mean,
that's literally like the mindset of
that tweet.
It's just silly tweet.
Hopefully he'll find another path.
I mean,
hopefully he's a is.
Are you dIsturbed?
I don't know if I'm even disturbed
anymore If I'm kinda like,
oh,
if I'm numb in a.
Yeah,
in a kind of a.
I dunno,
like domestic situation where I was just
like,
yeah,
domestic violence.
So yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Like your wife.
That's what he said.
Yeah.
He went to Texas and,
and like to see the flood damage and was
like,
yeah,
good crowd.
Big crowd.
that's what it is.
It's kind of crowd.
What a crowd here to see me right now?
Everybody.
Yay.
no,
I don't think.
I don't think I'm disturbed.
I just don't think it was.
I knew it would be bad.
I don't think it would be this,
get this bad,
this court this quick and yeah,
it's really,
it's fascinating.
The thing that fascinates me the most,
it's not just him,
but how many people still support him?
How many pieces of any problem with it?
Yeah,
I try to.
I can't understand it really with a.
They still are behind you behind all of
this or is it just where they have a
similar.
Just the people that are really into
him.
Are they the same type of just egomaniac
or a narcissist is where they can't
admit wrong or they know that it's
wrong,
but that I can't.
I'm locked in now.
They're locked in.
I think they're finding a way to justify
whatever he does no matter what it is.
Like I had a cow bell yesterday on the
podcast.
I didn't read.
I don't read comments on youtube,
but I did look at the thumbs up,
thumbs down and it's like he had as many
thumbs down as thumbs up.
That's super rare and I think a lot of
it was because he was talking a lot of
shit about trump.
We were both were.
We were talking about how ridiculous
this is and I saw a couple of comments
on twitter,
people that got mad because we were
talking about his response to
charlottesville and they were saying he
was saying on all sides because there
was violence on all sides,
like people showed up with torches.
They showed up wIth torches for white
folks.
They were like,
we're here for white folks only we have
torches like you don't.
You don't think that's an issue.
You don't think people showing up a line
of crazy white supremacists with torches
and the people that were opposing them,
the people that are opposing them.
Yeah,
they fucked up too,
but the only reason why we're there
we're there is because there was people
with torches.
The whole thing is insane
is a and he doesn't have the.
I mean he doesn't know how to handle it
and I was like,
he can't say that publicly.
He can say,
hey guys,
I'm panicking right now.
No,
he never said that,
but he can't say it explicitly,
but he kinda says it through his ax.
I don't think he's healthy.
Also too.
I think when you're 70 years old,
like you were talking about,
like your brain gets older,
you're 34,
right?
I'm 50 now.
My brain's getting older for sure.
What's it gonna be like in 22,
23 years.
So what does he took?
Third,
71,
72,
something like that.
What's that going to be like?
Not good.
I don't think you should be working all
day.
Yeah.
That dude,
uh,
he's too old and he's a,
he's a crazy person.
And he used to host the apprentice and
he was on comedy central roast amongst
other things
to watch.
That's not to say that those things,
uh,
I mean you can't be solid at a being
president,
but this guy,
you say he still watches five hours of
tv a day.
That's what I read yesterday.
Who reported that?
Routers,
If I find a bunch of fake news,
how could anybody have time to watch
five hours of tv a day if you have a
real job?
Wasn't brand new particle,
but trump's session is a first look at
that hair.
Hilarious.
Like that they can just take a photo of
his hair.
Only black,
everything out.
That is the most bizarre image of a
president.
That crazy helmet of hair got mixed it
up.
when you have a photo editor,
it's a good move actually because no
president has consumed as much hold on.
Nope.
Presidents confused as much television
in the current one or reacted as quickly
or directly to what they're seeing.
He loves fox and frIends.
Six 24:00 AM monday.
Trump gushed over twitter about the
amazing reporting and quotes on the
morning talk show a week earlier.
He instructed the nation to in parenths
in quotes,
watch fox and friends now for their
exemplary really Russia coverage.
Exemplary.
Really laurie exemplary Russia coverage.
He tweeted about the program hosted by
steve dewey dokey duty.
How do you say that?
Juicy,
juicy dukie dukie like poo a aynsley.
What are these people's names?
Ainslie earnhardt and brian kilmeade
seven times in march alone.
And uh,
recently brought up,
brought it up in an interview with fox
news' tucker carlson,
telling him cheerfully.
I liked that group of three people
even after becoming president.
Trump reportedly manages to fIll his
days with plenty of television in quotes
and from his tweets.
It's often possible to discern when and
what he's watching,
and january,
axios broke down the president's media
diet.
Most mornings,
trump flicks on the tv and watch his
morning joe,
but he hates that guy now.
Not anymore.
Now he hates that guy.
He talk shit about his wife's plastic
surgery often for long periods of time,
sometimes interrupted with text to the
host or panelists.
He Texts them after the 6:00 AM hour of
joe.
He's often onto fox and friends.
Wow.
What a little cnn before or after,
just to fucking get the blood pressure
up.
He also catches the sunday show,
especially meet the press,
the shows,
as he calls them,
often provoke his tweets.
The day of our interview with him,
all of his tweet topics were discussed
and we've discussed during the first two
hours of morning,
joe,
wow.
Five hours of television every Day says,
yes,
I got fIve a day,
but too much.
And also he is weird that the president
is easily debatable on twitter.
More so to me,
you see when stephen colbert got them
and then colby said,
you know,
mr,
president,
as much as I think you're terrible,
it'd be the president.
I thought the very least you understood
show business and goes,
you responded to me because that means I
won.
I got you.
Yeah.
That was when he called,
when he called trump's mouth at cock
holster for putin.
Oh,
it as a great job.
It was a great joke,
but it's crazy like seeing that on a
late night talk show,
a late night talk show on cbs.
The hosts calls the president's mouth.
Believe caught.
I don't know what they did.
They probably it.
But you knew what it was.
Yeah,
a coc.
He's saying that
he know what he's saying,
but the fact that that was in the
monologue that cbs is like,
yeah,
go for it.
I mean,
no other president do.
You would never have that.
Not in a million years.
The elect,
the minimal amount of respect.
No fcc fined for stephen colbert.
Late night.
Donald trump cock holster crack.
Wow.
Yeah.
They believed it was trump trying to go
after it for the fcc.
Do you remember when the fcc went after
howard stern?
People forget about that shit.
He got fined and he didn't even swear he
got fined hundreds of thousands of
dollars.
Shit.
Yeah.
How do you think how you think it is his
guy?
You think he ends his term?
You think he dies in office?
You think he,
uh,
he gets impeached.
You think what happens with trump?
That's a good question.
I don't think he gets a second term,
but you think he makes it wrong.
I think he makes it to the end of the
term.
Yeah.
I think it's just how long wheels on a
giant disaster and it gets worse and
worse.
And I think.
Here's the thing that howard stern had a
really good point about trump.
He said he wants to be loved.
He wants people to love him.
This is a terrible job if you want
people to love you because even the
people that supported you,
once you get in there,
you're trying to do this impossible job
there.
Really.
No one's been able to do totally.
People forget that obama had like a very
low approval rating too at one point in
time in his presidency.
I think he was in the low forties,
like 44 percent or something like that.
Approval rating.
Like it's not a job that anybody does.
Well,
even if you're the best at ever,
you still people a giant percentage of
the population.
Millions and millions of people are
going to fucking hate you.
That's not,
I don't think that's in that guy psyche.
Especially if you check twitter like
that.
Yeah,
you can.
you can block himself from it a when he
broke,
he blocks regular people when regular
people black himself from that.
Yes.
But just like by delete that off his
phone,
he can kinda get away from it,
but I don't think he could just take
that attention away from him.
So no,
I don't think so either.
I just don't think it's healthy for
them,
especially at this late stage of his
life,
you know,
seventies taking this kind of heat
because before he was president,
that guy,
whether people,
some people didn't like,
um,
some people loved them,
no big deal.
He was genuinely generally able to like
walk around everywhere and not be hated.
Like he'd go to restaurant.
People go,
oh look,
there's Donald Trump.
There's no,
no.
People were like hating him.
His face kind of a douche bag maybe.
I like how you said that.
Maybe goes back,
whatever.
That was tough over there.
Nobody was better.
Yeah.
They might laugh or by try to get a
selfie with them and asked him a
question,
but now the amount of hate he
experiences is probably like four or 500
percent more,
more even ramped up through the roof.
It's a five digit weird number or
something crazy quantifiable.
Hey
man.
With the weird hair from the apprentice.
Yeah.
everybody just wants to take a free shot
at them too.
Like everywhere he goes,
poor bastard.
people are building goddamn careers off
of hate.
The trump,
the president's show on comedy central.
That's true.
God damn cold bear has been founded in
the radiance lately because he's been
ripping on him because I making that
goddamn legacy off of this being an
asshole.
People mad at fallon because found too
nice to him when he was running for
president.
The hair thing.
I mean it was already a done deal.
Then you think fallon was gone run?
No,
but it was that fallon didn't grill him.
He didn't.
It didn't pressure him.
That's when people are mad at that.
He didn't treat him like a dangerous
person.
ProbablY had no idea that he was going
to win too.
Yeah,
it was jokey at that point.
Had had play one of those weird games
and then cheated.
Fuck you with her face.
Big smile muscles.
His hair up.
Uh hm.
Very weird.
Yeah.
It's very weird.
It's just so strange that that's our
president.
It's hard to believe sometimes.
LIke sometimes I'll stare at the news
and I just have to look at it for like
seconds,
like 10,
15 seconds.
Just go,
okay,
this is real.
This is real.
This is the really.
Is the president Donald Trump,
have you traveled abroad yet?
Wouldn't ms.
President?
Yeah.
Italy.
Italy to with the fam.
Yeah.
How was it?
Just normal.
Nobody gives a shit is normal.
There's no.
They don't give a fuck.
They're over there doing Italy shit.
But you were doing a.
So use this vacation.
No shows.
Yeah.
I'm sure if you go some.
I've been to Canada to do shows,
but I'm sure if you go and do shit.
Have I wait a minute?
No,
I haven't.
The first.
My shirt first shows with trump as
president will be next weekend.
Edmonton.
Yeah.
No,
I haven't.
I haven't been anywhere while he's
actually been the president.
It's going to be a trip man.
Yeah,
they just kinda blamed it on.
you would have in the few conversations
I've had when I've been out of the
country.
That was.
What are you guys doing over there?
Yeah.
Well they have a situation that's the
exact opposite.
They have a super liberal president that
was letting in any immigrants and now
he's apparently cooled off on that too
because doctor having it.
Yeah.
Trudeau also,
they're having issues with free speech,
you know,
people are getting fined for saying
things,
they're setting up these weird laws
where you can get in deep shit for ms
dot gendering.
People not using the correct gender
pronouns,
one of 78 different gender pronouns that
people use now.
LIke they're super ultra left wing,
like his cabinet and his ideas.
He's a real like legitimate social
justice
warrior president.
So it's interesting.
It's like,
yeah,
both schools,
right?
Right next to each other desk.
Both of them are kind of fucked.
yeah.
Yeah.
Wait,
we did it.
They did it to Russia.
Did it.
Nobody should fucking be president meant
nobody shouldn't be president.
Oh,
heartache.
We need more.
We need a group of humans as a group of
12.
Yeah.
Caligiuri.
Something like that.
Yeah.
And uh,
a group oF intelligent people that are
qualified,
like with like a great education,
excellent ethics,
great morals.
You can't have just a popularity contest
to see who gets to control the nukes.
It's fucking crazy.
I hope we get at.
I hope we get past it,
but I don't think we're going to.
I think once we have things written on
paper,
once we have like a way that we operate,
once we have some sort of a plan that we
follow,
it's very difficult to get to people to
shake that too,
to have some sort of a new reasonable
plan to run the country without
representative government,
you know,
like senators and congressmen and people
that you have to like it mean they had
all that shit back when they couldn't
get ahold of people.
I mean,
theY had all the,
all that stuff was.
And I'm not saying that there shouldn't
be some representatives.
I'm saying that the system that's in
place right noW was really in place
right now because you had a
representative every state and they had
to travel to dc and they did their
business.
Then they come back to their
constituents.
Will,
the constituents can all communicate in
real time.
Now.
I mean,
we have this,
uh,
unique ability now to share your
opinions and even to vote online.
That also should be an option 100
percent.
We should be voting online.
Uh,
I don't know about that.
That could be,
that could be easily.
I mean if the picks on the cloud,
he's worried about people voting online.
Listen,
who knows?
That's just a dark dick.
The bad guy
be anybody's hasn't played a voice,
a voice that's saying anything that is
fake neWs.
Fake news,
ruder photo shopped
better.
System is possible.
This is not the best system.
I feel like this is like trying to patch
up windows 95 over and over again.
Just come up with a new yes,
a couple of years old.
Come up,
mix it up,
mix it up.
But you know,
that's gonna take a lot of time.
A lot of time to do what's in the notes,
man.
We gotta do it.
All right.
Everything a pretty.
We got to it organically.
Yeah,
I mean,
yeah,
I didn't try it.
I didn't.
I'm not a,
you know,
I'm not a hammer it in type.
You know what I did the morning radio
type of unit.
That's the worst.
Oh,
so what do you want to talk about those
still do,
do morning radio shows?
Uh,
no I haven't done them in aWhile.
I,
I'll,
uh,
no,
and
I don't even those call in and I
understand that you were at a baseball
game or a baseball game.
Baseball.
Super boring.
No,
we got through everything except for
weirdly the one.
Uh,
you know,
congratulations on a thousand episodes.
Thanks.
By the way,
I started a podcast last year.
Oh,
that's right.
Yeah.
Handsome rambler.
Who?
It's really nice.
It was a high name.
I'm locked into it now.
Consider changing it.
It's fun.
No,
it's been good.
Do you have guests have guests on do it?
We do it all over.
We do it like we,
it's me and my dj tony trimm.
Uh,
so we do a lot of them in chicago,
but we travel and yeah,
it's uh,
we,
we have comedians and we have a lot of
musicians on.
We one for you to do it.
I do.
We put them out every week,
but we block record them just because
I'm usually traveling a lot.
So we just,
we have a chairman and we got,
we do make goofy songs.
We set,
that's a,
that's tony's crypt and chicago.
Oh,
that's nice setup there.
Yeah.
So we,
we played some songs and shit and goof
off and do some interview stuff.
It's a fun time though.
It's been good.
Nice.
It's kinda,
it's kinda changed,
you know,
uh,
how I,
I feel like I'm a.
When I talked to people I feel like a
better person,
not because I have a podcast,
but I feel like I'm more in tune with
what a person is saying.
Yeah.
We're like,
am I ended up accidentally interviewing
people when you talk to them in real
life,
but like asking good,
quite weird like nat and a practicing
way where I ended up talking to people
but asking better questions then the
where you from.
So the,
the getting beyond the surface level.
So I think that's happened because of
that.
Well I,
I feel like the same thing with me.
I've learned how to be a better
conversation with you evolve for sure.
You also learn what's annoying about
your speech patterns.
Oh,
you say a lot of years.
Yeah,
that's what I say.
Like a lot.
Like it's like there's like,
you know,
and like those are big ones.
yeah.
You know,
like,
and yeah,
because I just say three years,
five seconds.
We,
you also learned how bad,
like a lot of regular people are at
having actual conversations.
A lot of people just waiting for you to
stop talking so they can talk like
they're barely paying attention to what
you're saying.
Yeah.
Being a good conversationalist.
It's huge.
Is
A lot of tools.
Yeah.
Did you,
did you read books and shit when you
first started or did you just go into it
or did you,
did you study certain people when you,
as you went along or when you first
started?
No,
no,
no.
Total trial and error.
Just doing it a lot.
you know,
in a thousand episodes we've done a
thousand episodes
plus another 40 that were like fight
companions,
podcasts on a plane,
podcasts on a hike.
There's a bunch of dIfferent ones.
Fight breakdowns.
How often do you listen to it?
What do you watch?
I listened to occasionally I listened to
one if I think it sucks.
If I think I was bad or if I think,
uh,
the person said something super
interesting,
like there was one the other day with
Sean Carroll.
He's an astrophysicist and a,
he's a,
an expert and quantum theory and it's
just shit.
He was saying it's so hard to grab a
hold of.
I had to listen to it several times
then.
Yeah.
But it's mostly just me asking questions
and hear him talk and.
But it's just the stuff that he's saying
is so intense,
you got to kind of listen to it over and
over again with my feeble little brain
just to try to store it,
you know,
like,
okay,
what is he saying?
And there's another one,
this woman that she's on all the time,
rhonda,
patrick,
dr rhonda,
patrick specialty,
um,
nutritional absorption and just,
uh,
how nutrients affect the body.
That's the big thing with her.
And she's,
she's one of the smartest people I've
ever talked to him.
He's freaky smart,
like,
like almost like an alien,
like you talking to and you realize how
dumb you are because you can ask her a
question about something and not only
can she tell you what it is,
she'll recite the studies that were done
and what percentages?
The studies and it's just pulling this
right out of it in between our ears.
She's not.
Nope.
Nope,
pewter into.
She has notes but she rarelY uses them
when she comes on the podcast.
She'll like,
have something that she wants to talk
about some new study on,
like,
you know,
like broccoli sprouts was one that she
went over the last time because she's
been experimenting with broccoli sprouts
and she's a clinical researcher as well,
so she does actual scientific research.
So she's one of them that I listened to
like several times to try to remember
what the fuck she was saying.
So does she hit you up the same way?
I actually,
joe got this broccoli sprouts shit I
need to get off sometimes.
Yeah.
Sometimes
say I'll hit her up too because she's a
researcher too,
because she's always like a,
for lack of a better word,
balls deep in research and she,
she's like,
sometimes she doesn't have time to do
podcasts.
He's in the middle of so many different
things that she's working on.
Actual science,
you know,
that's the interesting thing about
having real scientists on as you realize
like what a different world they live
in.
Absolutely.
I would never have a scientist.
You might enjoy it maybe down the line,
but right now I keep it to five pula.
Yeah.
Keep It fun and people I know and I
think it may be down in line as I grow
at it.
Then I be able to carry that kind of
conversation with confidence or at least
lead them into what they want to say
and,
and asking engaging questions during it.
But for right now,
keeping it,
rappers,
comedians,
musicians,
is fun.
Some of my favorite podcasts that I do,
or like comedians,
like yourself or my friends or um,
one thing I cAn tell you though,
looking at that image of you guys,
this is what a mistake that we did when
we first started out.
We did it on couches.
Problem with couches is you got to like
sit forward where the microphone is not
that comfortable.
Like I realized after awhile,
I see how you guys are like,
everybody's leaning forward looking at
that.
See like on this show,
you're sitting in these ergonomic office
chairs.
You're sitting in the back and,
but you're sitting up and you could sit
here for hours and hours at a time.
If you do three hours,
sit the way byron powers is right there.
That shit's gonna hurt your back.
Oh,
well we,
we,
we keep about an hour and a half or so
hour and a half's good.
Yeah,
that's right when it starts swing.
But like office chairs are the way to
go.
There's a reason why they make these
things like,
especially these ergonomic ones,
these are from a ergo depot.
They're called capisce [inaudible].
For people that ask and they're,
um,
they're not a sponsor or anything,
they just,
they're bad ass chairs and they force
you to sit up straight so you can sit in
these for hours and it doesn't fuck with
your back.
Solid tip,
joe rogan.
Solid tip.
I appreciate it.
I made those mistakes.
I had a couch and ari shaffir took that
couch.
He sold it.
I gave it to him and he did something
with it.
I think he evaded or something that
everybody knows the couch.
look at this.
Go on here.
Oh,
it's happening here.
That's uh,
we went,
uh,
mogue fest.
What does that mogue fest.
Moga is the company they make
synthesizes.
So a lot of bands you'll see they use
milk products.
And so,
um,
that there are many that we use on a
podcast,
you know,
that there are many is the instrument
that you can operate with waves,
like just you move your hands around it.
They make that.
And so tony,
my,
he said,
oh,
we should go to mogue fest.
And so I could be.
That's a good idea.
That had festivals in durham.
So I reached out to them and they,
uh,
they said she'll come to the fast and we
did a couple of podcasts there and then
also they have a,
a,
a workshop where you can build your own
drum synthesizer.
So it's a two day workshop where you
built it,
they give you all the parts and you
build it from scratch and you do all the
solder it and school.
So I built this a drum at the size of
it.
It may.
Is that what you're doing there?
Is that what's in your hand?
That's a,
at that point you have soldering right
there.
Yeah.
So that's like a.
What is that?
What are those boards called?
Circuit boards.
Circuit board.
Yeah.
So yeah,
we both worked on,
I didn't do all the work,
but uh,
I did a lot of.
That was my first time soldering
anything was doing.
I hadn't done actual building shit with
my hands in a long time,
but yeah.
Then we,
uh,
then when we built them all,
everybody built their as an in,
at the end of the class,
linked them all together and they just,
it just kinda fucked around with them
and just make crazy noise.
Wow.
Yeah,
that's interesting.
It was fun,
man.
That seems pretty bad ass.
Yeah.
Making your own sense.
So that's a cool.
What does,
just off a whim,
you just decided to go and do that?
Well,
we were,
cause yeah,
we just a,
I looked it up and it was a bunch of
artists that I liked there too.
And so it just,
and we reached out to that was kind of a
chill festival is it,
have some bigger artists,
but it's still pretty small in the way
that we were able to hit them up a few
weeks before and they were able to
accommodate us with time slots and say
okay,
they will already have somebody
interview flying lotus.
So they had us intervieW him and uh,
we interview animal collective and they
were pretty low.
It was just loosen and,
and chill and it was easy to navigate.
It was a,
it was a fun festival.
Yeah,
it was just on a whim.
So do you use that thing now?
That's kind to be like kind of
satisfying knowing that you made
something and I haven't used it yet
because it's set my,
I had to get it from,
from New York and uh,
bring it to chicago and started using
it.
I use the theremin mordo that there,
ms.fun.
So like what do you make music?
We make songs on the podcast.
We do a,
instead of doing an ad read,
we do a,
we do a jingle for you to do an original
song for each ad.
So you write the songs that you like,
what their talking points.
Uh,
we do well,
we do the,
we do the song and it's kind of hooky.
Usually just based is saying the same
like we got bev was one our sponsor,
so we go blah,
blah blah blah blah blah.
And he'll produce around it.
and then we'll do to read after the,
uh,
the saw this is that there are many that
he's talking about to wave your hands
over it and it makes music,
millimeter stereo headphone out.
The other antenna will control that hand
technique.
I usually do a full openhand that's mars
shit.
It's real weird.
That's a weird,
weird thing.
But it's fun man in it.
so we've made some beats with that.
That's fascinating.
I've never heard of this thing before.
Yeah,
we really used that.
I mean we have an tonio,
he'll have a drum machine.
We got a microphone that does like auto
tune and stuff.
Wow.
So it's really to cover up that we're a
bad interviews,
you'll be alone and we can't take us
out.
He was like,
it just started goofing off and make it
a.
So do you think like you'd probably not
an interview.
Are you just having a conversation?
Right?
Yeah.
Well how many podcasts are really,
right?
Absolutely.
But I,
I just,
uh,
I could talk,
you know what I mean?
But I also want to be,
when I,
when I have a guest,
I want to like put them in a position to
shot,
you know what I mean?
And so sometimes I'll catch myself kind
of going off and I'm like,
oh shit,
let me get it back to them.
You know what I mean?
We use that thing.
what?
No,
I'll catch myself going off onto a,
uh,
into a long ass story to now realize
that.
Let me just bring it back and get it to
a.
So this guest.
Yeah,
that's what I mean.
Yeah.
That's fun.
It's fun.
No,
it's a fun time.
as long as it's fun,
man.
That's everything.
do you find that like a lot of people
that are coming to your shows,
they,
uh,
they listen to the podcast and it's sort
of like gets you closer to them?
Yeah,
it is where we get a lot of messages
about it and people say they've bought
their minis because you're like,
I didn't,
I didn't even know what a theremin he
was,
but now I want one because they play it
so god goddamn much.
And it's kind of a running theme on the
show were the guest of a what is that
thing and be like,
hey,
that's a therapist.
So It's just kind of a,
it's almost like a third host of the
show when the person finds out what it
is.
And I explained it pretty much
every time.
It's a fun time.
And uh,
so tell people that it's handsome,
rambler,
itunes,
soundcloud,
the other ones.
what is it?
What else you got?
What is it like google play,
google play,
play.
It's amazing how few people bring up
google play because like half the people
have android dome thing isn't like
google play never gets discussed.
And you can get google play on an iphone
too,
right?
but you can't get itunes.
can you get itunes on an android phone?
You can't get the podcasts on google
play on the iphone because there's a
podcast app which google apps on the
phone or whatever.
They don't let you.
But they let you use some podcast apps,
right?
I don't know,
just that comedy podcasts app,
that arch fear is always,
is different though.
That's a comedy app that's aggregating.
Let's see how many things.
They wouldn't let you choose an actual
podcast app other than there?
I don't think so.
I could be speaking,
but I don't think so.
Yeah,
man,
it's a tough road for those android
people.
It's tough road.
People just look at you illegitimately
if you green text message,
but yeah,
they get weirded out by here.
You bought one,
you get crazy red.
The cameras really made one day to sit
down and I was like,
ooh.
It looks tremendous.
They made an android phone.
It hasn't.
They just showed up.
Put up a picture where you can only see
like the corner and the rest of it's all
shaded out.
I'll see if I can find it real quick.
No,
that dude,
marcus got ahold of one and then I saw
the video but I already bought it
before.
Now I just kind of went ahead and
because they had some wording on the
bottom that like there's gonna be some
special things that you won't be able to
buy if you don't Buy in this window.
It was a whole sales pitch,
but like I just went ahead and bought a
house.
So you're going to switch over to
android.
That switch.
It'll just be like a second.
Whoa.
Phone.
You're gonna have a whole phone.
It doesn't work.
I'll sell it and just what it's supposed
to also be a modular something or other.
For the new cameras they're going to
have coming out too,
so it'll actually be a physical tool.
It's more or less Just a five inch
screen.
That's a tool for these.
These cameras that don't have any
screens on those red cameras for people
don't know.
There's a lot of television shows a good
with those like super high end high
definition.
Top of the food chain caMeras.
that new phone does look dope and it's
got like these crazy grips on the side
of it.
Like the side of it is not smooth.
It's got like finger holes,
like where your.
Your hanD grips onto it.
What they had to been doing great as a
camera company where they said let's do
phones also holographic.
Yeah.
Well marcus is the video.
What is marcus's last name?
Brownlee.
There was a video where marcus is
watching it and he's like,
whoa,
you can't show you that.
It looks like he said he can't show you.
Goes,
you can tell shit.
You could see my reaction to it and by
the way,
he's like,
the reaction is not even to the finished
product,
which would be even better than it is
now,
but you see how the aside edges have
those weird grips to it.
It's really kind of interesting.
Yeah,
he's a mess and with it.
But you could see like when he's holding
it in his hand,
like what it looks like.
Is that it just talking about it?
I think that's a different video than
the one I saw.
Maybe it's not.
He was on a couch.
Yeah,
there it is.
And you see the thing,
it doesn't look like any other phone
you've ever seen before.
Like yeAh,
there you go.
Like see the sides of it.
It's all like,
it's got like ripples.
Like finger slots.
Yeah,
real big too.
Huge.
Bigger than life.
But he's got big hands so you can't tell
as much.
I got tiny hands.
I'd be trapped in this shit.
To you.
which one do you have?
A regular iphone?
Yeah.
I didn't get the one because my hands
can't enter this shit.
You got to end it,
but there's so much.
It's so worth it.
If you go online,
like if you go online,
you want to read something online,
it's just so much better with the big
screen.
It's just the experience and looking at
pictures and videos of fireworks and
shit.
Holographic displays.
Interesting.
I'm a little worried too that they
announced something they won't be able
to deliver on,
which happens from time to time.
Oh,
jamie'S mr.
Pegaworld,
size difference.
The uh,
the red marketing person went from
really excited to go
a full on hype piece until,
I don't know if they're going to be able
to do it.
you're going to get a bunch of ads on
twitter was like zero posts.
Like fuck you,
you piece of shit.
Yeah.
There's um,
at galaxy note eight looks insane too.
That's coming out real soon.
That's like almost out.
They don't still make the airplane
announcements.
No,
that was a seven.
Yeah.
They don't make it anymore.
Pretty much everybody's got rid of that
thing.
If you're a hold out,
you're like,
oh fuck,
I charge it.
But I charged it up,
take a pot from my,
uh,
from my stove.
I charged in that fucking thing.
Just gauging catches fire,
put it in the fireplace.
You see that little video showing how
people to,
if they're in the floods,
how to charge their phones off of a nine
volt battery and a,
and a in a key.
Yeah,
it lookS sketchy.
But in a nine volt battery,
uh,
put the in a car charger.
I'm on the internet too much.
It's unplugged.
Does happen.
Oh,
it was a different lady I saw.
Okay.
So she's got a car charger and she takes
the car charger and sticks on the end of
a nine volt battery,
like One,
one of the slots and then puts a key in
the other slot and I think you've got to
touch it.
You get the circuit.
What if this lady just burst into flames
and lost her islands so you can get
electrocuted by doing this.
So yeah,
be careful.
But It's a nine volt battery.
You can.
And obviously won't be a big charge,
I don't think,
but it will charge the phone.
so she touches the two of them together.
Wow.
That works.
That's crazy.
That's nuts.
So if you're in a pinch and all you got
to nine volt battery and you need to
call nine slash 11,
they make a battery adapter for an
iphone.
Why don't they make a little thing where
you can plug a nine volt battery into
it.
Just go to a store,
buy a battery,
plugged that fucker in and charge your
phone.
Does anybody have that?
How do they not have that?
Because they have those banks,
you know,
there's a power bank so that you can
plug your shit into.
It seems like somebody would have this.
Have you seen that new,
um,
a luggage that you could ride?
Have you seen that shit?
Turns it into a scooter.
Yes.
Yeah.
Hey,
that's fucking amazing.
What does that,
I don't know.
I re tweeted it the other day though,
was on mashable and I was like,
get the fuck out of here.
The thing goes eight miles an hour.
You sit on a fucker and you ride around
the airport with it as a.
It's legit.
I said related.
That's one way to stunt.
That's one way to handle a layover.
just drive around the airport until
your,
your luggage runs out of batteries,
but you can also use the battery
charging of that,
the battery and use It to charge your
phone.
Like you can plug your phone into that.
That alone is worth it.
Like always having battery power,
right?
They're connected to your luggage.
That's a lot of the.
A lot of these,
uh,
luggages are doing that now.
Look at that.
Get the fuck out of here.
And that's a carry on.
Yes.
People having a good old time.
I have to go.
I got to get online and media bias.
Come on.
What
is it called?
a mob moto bag.
Come on.
Look.
See?
She's fitting her stuff in there and
then she drives off.
We will look at this.
She could plug into it.
That's what I like to see.
You write that in an airport though.
I'll do it.
I don't think I do it.
You don't know if I do it.
What you can do it.
Does that.
What was that?
She had a gyroscope.
Is that real?
I'm getting that backup a little bit
right there.
and then there's just a segue just to
show you.
Oh,
is there a standard option?
Uh,
can uh,
can you stand up?
Can they handle bars?
Go up?
And then
this is why that doesn't work because I
can fail.
Fail.
Yeah.
But this is a guy that's just rolling
around on it like an asshole.
Oh,
this is that dude that's on youtube.
Who's that guy?
Casey something?
Yeah,
he's got.
He's famous on youtube.
Is that his apartment?
That's his,
uh,
his office.
Whoa.
What is he doing in there?
Making a frankenstein's monster makes
all kinds of videos and films and shit.
He's been making movies on youtube and
hbo for 15 years or something.
I know it's kinda crazy workshop,
man you've ever seen in brooklyn or
something.
Makes them one of those dudes a broad
manhattan broadway,
somewhere like that.
Interesting.
He's got shop bAck on fathers always on
right there.
Oh yeah.
The godfather Is always on her father.
Wanted to,
on a constant loop.
I'm about to go back to school to man.
Let's wrap this up.
Hannibal.
Tell everybody where you're going to be.
They want to see you.
Go do stand up.
Oh,
I'll be a.
I'm on a b in camden,
New Jersey.
And uh,
bristol,
Virginia with no Lauren Hill and
september 14,
15.
Uh,
and then uh,
talked to Lauren Hill about taxes.
I haven't talked to her.
I haven't swiped we haven't done any
dates together yet.
They talk about taxes.
I don't know.
I say locked her up.
Lock her up.
It's so weird.
Backstage convault for first meeting.
Hey.
So,
uh,
taxes and stuff.
That's crazy.
Her up as a jail in jail for like a
couple of years I think.
Yeah.
But yeah,
now she's out.
She's out in turin somehow.
Me,
Lauren Hill.
Nah,
that's amazing.
On a tour.
I think chrome mix is one of the other
acts.
Uh,
we'll be in seattle,
bay area miami,
uh,
san diego and playing hollywood bowl
October 5th.
Beautiful.
And uh,
all my dates.
Hannibal buress.com.
So check me out this fault.
Check him out.
Ladies and gentlemen,
thanks joe.
My pleasure.
All right folks,
this fucking podcast.
It's over.
Live your lives.
Thank you so much.
Bye.